two
hello everybody it is Friday
after Dark
it's all happening today it's a rainy
day out here in Los Angeles it really is
it's actually a lovely day here in Los
Angeles uh welcome everybody today's
episode is sponsored by Shopify who we
love love love
thank you to our sponsor we love them
how are you doing today Ela thank you
I'm doing great how are you
feeling a little uh stiff
I can see that yeah unfortunately
um
I'm having to do the voice from home and
so we had to stand in I don't know I'm
just kidding this is the thing how he
gave us hold on
wow
the crowd loved that one thank you guys
oh wait should I meant to can you give
me a uh one of the shirts from the new
drop I just wore this shirt from home
um but I meant to change hello everybody
that's how we made me that pillow pretty
Epic
yeah and creepy very creepy it was in
our house for two days and everybody was
creeped out by it myself included yeah
me too and Brucie well
Daddy and then you take my hand and take
me there and go Daddy
cute so how's your week been illa it's
been good
um
pregnant okay that's good news oh yeah
yeah so today's the day I'll get to wear
that one yeah so like this is a the
Friday's a big deal yeah you know no
restrictions on Friday you know you guys
use a lot of green right Friday's off
the rails clothing lines you guys use a
lot of green and yes we do I don't know
it's a color we use color
they do they do yeah it is a color yep
huge color yeah oh that's nice let's go
nice oh I was gonna say we have a great
show planned today we have
um some great segments where I become a
donut Daddy
explain that a little bit yeah I'm
getting an explanation
uh we've got uh
and also me and love are going to be
doing the pain simulator one because
love wasn't here and so he's got to go
through the gauntlet right now this one
is making me nervous I will say it's not
a big deal
we'll hold hands sure
I think it's nothing compared to the
spices yeah this is way although yeah
you didn't care about the spicy one no
that's true maybe uh maybe I can handle
it I don't know and so um people were
saying oh cause you lost weight
I was complaining that it hurt a lot
because I was saying maybe it's because
I'm fat and it's conducting through my
fat I don't I'm not I'm not a you know a
chemist I don't know about conduct how
fat conducts electricity or anything but
I'm gonna try it again now that I lost
weight so there that is and Gabe here
beautiful blurred out are you blurred
out right there Gabe
now I'm preparing this bracelet going to
this Taylor Swift concert tonight
how'd you score one of those tickets
I got from some some guy down the street
guy down the street
what do you mean guy down the street you
gotta you got Taylor Swift tickets from
a guy down the street
yep I'm excited to go did you buy them
oh yeah how much were they
like 300 300 per really
yeah that seems like a good deal from
what I've heard pricey but I'm walking
tonight with the Taylor Swift baby I've
heard people spending way way more than
that
what's your favorite t-swift song or
album
I like this one song is this not too
late
that one I like that one hell yeah dude
hopefully she plays that one for you
shake it off I love that one
me too why do you keep showing the
bracelets what's going on there
it's like a friendship bracelet it's
kind of like my thing going to the
concert tonight you're gonna swap with
people
yeah do you swap bracelets with people
at the concert
I don't know it's probably a thing I
guess some ship bracelets yeah yeah
usually I mean I've the only time I've
seen those is that like Raves when
people are all blasted on ecstasy no
this is a Taylor
aerostore thing as people bring
friendship bracelets with little beads
cute yeah
uh she really has the best community
she's really something isn't she
you're right she really is something
all right well that's very exciting Gabe
anything else going on
I think that's about it
concert and
Hitler's show today wait Gabe there's a
problem
what there's no Taylor Swift show
tonight
what the
the hold on who sold you those
tickets
I got tickets for nothing what the
no do you have the tickets I'm reading
that the tour is over
oh man you mean to say that there's no
concert tonight is this guy lying to me
what the uh pumped up and all this
are you gonna be
able to get your money back from him it
sounds like you got kind of burned there
are so many scammers out there yeah for
a ticket what a lot what a
piece of okay all right well that's
okay I mean so I think the door is over
they're saying yeah the tour is like
totally over
well do you have the bracelets is there
anyone who can maybe just swap bracelets
with is there any Taylor Swift fans who
are willing to swap bracelets with Gabe
would that maybe
be a record related
[Music]
got wrecked
reconcilable
uh gesture for you
it ain't good okay
true that's what I learned in life
well let that be a lesson to everybody
out there that's a shame man that sucks
dude that's a real piss in my ass
that's a real piss in my ass brother do
you know where he lives is there
anything we like can we go hit him up
not me but like can you I have no clue
maybe somebody knows it's a good hustle
he's got
all right Gabe all right well
listen
[Music]
thank you
I was close though the bell comes in
yeah it almost breaks me it's so serious
next time I see you in person we gotta
lock eyes for real and just
Embrace each other's gaze yeah sure
all right buddy you have a great weekend
I know you will
thanks baby thanks sorry about that
Taylor Swift man yeah it's just not
right that's not okay
well uh always a pleasure my uh to speak
with thank you Lena to a white or not
White Cloud Gabe sorry Uncle Gabe
the artist formerly known as white Club
yeah
man Gabe is getting screwed over by
everybody first White claw
now Taylor Swift people are screwing him
over yeah although I don't know about
the strategy of just finding people on
the street yeah there's random people
now Taylor didn't scam him it was no no
I didn't no of course not no Taylor was
Stan Taylor
Taylor Taylor is universal Taylor it's
like a t see she knows what this means
see it's like a t duh
I'm sure I see it it'll catch on that's
the thesis so you want to show off your
fit today Ela sure is this like fairy
Chic what is this yeah
oh really I
need to do this uh braids around
I finally did it
like a steampunk angel
steampunk Angel fairy Chic
fairy dust I really need like a better
come back showing the fit
set up here
I think we need a little setup here to
show the fit you know
stand up on the chair you know what I
mean no
well check my Instagram tomorrow oh
okay girlies I will
how was your week though anything to
report I mean you were you watched the
xqc debate I thought you did great I've
been loving the whole xqc Saga okay yeah
the whole Arc is pretty interesting it
is very apparently he was in Vegas and
he posted Instagram he's like yo I just
lost 1.1 million I was like this dude's
about to be broke oh my gosh he actually
can waste all of his money probably not
though
oh how can you do that steak will keep
him bankrolled forever
yeah I got it actually speaking of Gabe
a good man he was at the picket line
forgot to show this
but him and his uncle
the whole family they're down there
supporting actually yeah and Gabe is he
sag after oh he is yeah he's definitely
sagged out
wow sag the out right now
well how was your awake
it was it was good I mean let's let's
look back
Monday was the xqc thing
Wednesday was
the xqc thing
Thursday was the xqc thing now me and me
and Hassan had a dip we talked a lot
yeah I watched the whole show you the
leftovers oh wow
[Laughter]
I thought it was a good conversation
obviously I agree with you thank you
that's all I wanted to hear
but
um I thought it was a good conversation
I saw some comments like Ethan he
doesn't care about the argument he just
wants to be right and I'm like okay
but in this case I am
and I do care about it yeah okay good oh
you're a fan yeah
I thought it was good that you both were
able to disagree but still
stay calm and talk about it you know you
know what it's a good example of like
how you can talk about something
yeah well he's dead to me I just didn't
say it I'm kidding but you know you made
a really good point and I've been
thinking about it yes you says oh yeah I
leaked my email too thank you yeah yeah
that was fun I leaked uh
X sending me a message that was fun
though people's that was well didn't
mean to do it oh The X yeah oh that's
not what I meant I thought the DMS yeah
so um
what xqc does he's not doing reactions
like let's not even call it's a watch
party yes a thousand percent he's not
analyzing he's not there to analyze it
he's there to watch it with his audience
that's a wash party yeah and watch
parties are not
transformative by Nature I think once
you call it that everybody agrees mm-hmm
we're all agreeing it's just that's it
what I'm calling what that is watch
party from now on dude because like I'm
not taking away chill Crowder I'm not
taking away from people who do that I
understand that it's fun to watch
something through the lens of somebody
else and they're like it's a watch party
but the party it's still a party
everyone's having fun but for you to put
it as your own content and make money
off of it despicable a different
conversation it's despicable frankly
so um disgusting uh let's see here so
let's let's get into the top of the show
here we got some Goose some gaps we're
having a call in from uh John from
Portugal the Man the guy who yes Zach
jammed out with at the Hollywood Bowl
it was unbelievable
and actually I have a daddy a donut
daddy segment that we've been planning I
have no idea what is that maybe we
should just get maybe we should do that
first it's pretty exciting
and
Oh wait we're not we're not ready yeah
it's not Daddy I saw a no from the back
we'll have to wait Indiana was like
there's there's some moving Parts still
so let's see xqc not to uh harp on that
but he's such a nice part let's harp a
little let me harp for a minute oh did
we want to do this Teddy fresh shout out
yes shout out
fresh new collection is out so many fun
sold out how cool is that so cool it's
my favorite
I'll give you guys a little scoop it's
gonna be re-releasing too in like a new
color and let's go a new fabrication so
what I what I think is so cool is that
this was like a pretty expensive piece
because it's a really a nice piece and
it's nice to see that people uh make you
know people are trusting us it really is
a nice point it's so cool but you know
what's so cool the crochet black shirt
right there yeah it's um almost sold out
wait I want that shirt that shirt's sick
I don't think I'd show titty but I would
like maybe wear a shirt it's so it
doesn't show that much you see on the
model I think you can totally wear it
without anything really yeah because I'm
like hairy and I've got curves yeah you
can wear a shirt I don't think it's for
a hairy curvy guy like me oh you're
perfect it's fine I think you can I
think it's so sick though I love it
love that anything else to say this is
all came out yesterday there's a couple
of restocks like that cardigan the
safety pin cardigan this one here yeah
and Don wanted the soccer mom it did
yeah
so that one was one of my the stupid
designs and some people were on the
fence about it
and right you were like I don't get it
um well I like so you were like about
the soccer mom I like the silhouette
yeah
but I I know I think it's good I came
around to it okay you know we were just
I came around I think it's really fun
yeah
and then um
it's so nice it's already sold out we
have it in the works in another colorway
yeah we gotta restock that this flower
had sick but it's not out yet hmm it
says coming I see it coming soon color
block cardigan some really cool uh
Illustrated this shirt oh it's not out
yet see I love that shirt too
anything you want to say about any of
this stuff it's all here it's all
happening this one is super cool too by
the way yes
this one's super cool only 95 that's a
good ass deal it's kind of like a
similar silhouette to the one that AB
was wearing with the stripes but this
one is Corduroy
and then a new messenger bag made
especially for Ethan dude I finally
upgraded my old corduroy bag basically
made this for you
I don't like any other bag it's just the
best so functional and perfect size this
is the shirt I'm wearing right now yes
and uh you can see it looks great
oh and the necklace is already sold out
I wanted to make sure people know that
the necklace is already a chain for your
pants too you can wear it on your pants
like from the belt loop to belt loop
it's long enough yeah and it has it has
clasp on yeah
you I think you got to start ordering
more jewelry because I noticed it always
sells out pretty fast that's really a
cool idea cool
I called this a shirt dress people are
making fun of me but I think you're not
wrong yeah that's what I call it yeah
thank you for supporting me not to
Endeavor I know people love these teddy
bear socks yeah
brown and black
oh you fancy bag
new in the in this bright neon pink
that's a new color
and this has some kind of nice fabric
right something going on with it it's I
believe was that one the Recycled
content
um I can't remember I don't want to say
it if I'm wrong I think it is yeah yeah
it is yeah I noticed it said recycled on
another product I clicked it and it
didn't say anything in the description
about it yeah
oh is it the other bag the duffel one
yeah this one I looked made with
partially recycled materials yeah okay
sometimes we can't get it fully 100 but
it could be like over 50 percent
um
there it is so it's all happening at
teddyfresh.com by CEO designer
uh
savant
mean that she's
has some deficiency or can savant
no no
I guess well okay so this is kind of
hard to get my way out of
but wait see it's a syndrome
is just a a person of learning yeah
detailed knowledge and some special
love that I didn't know Zach no
oh my God the Von syndrome in which
which persons with various developmental
disorders including autism have an
amazing ability or Talent yeah that's
okay that's the syndrome yeah that's
what I meant right oh that is sorry
sorry all right let's get out of this
fast you're saying you can use the word
servants without the syndrome
correct I'll take it that sounds awesome
let's just see Savant Define we're
learning here everybody too is it like
savvy
yeah like you and podcasting yeah well I
think yeah I probably more of this
like the uh film uh iconic uh of this
you know the Savant syndrome so I have
something similar to that and people who
watched me on
son uh see you next Tuesday understand
what I mean
yeah yeah yeah thank you guys all right
so let's talk about
um this dumbass xqc check this out and
there's a few things I just I'm sorry
oh there was a little crochet drama I
wonder if I should address it crochet
crochet drama crochet girlies called us
out and they were like you can't call
this crochet because crochet is made by
hand you're talking about the black
shirt no the sweater
[Music]
um
Vega they are technically right because
it's just with factories it's it's just
what we call it but it's a crochet
stitch made to look like crochet it's
made by a machine and so you got called
out yeah so it says they're right though
it's just internally we've all started
calling it
like that and technically no it's not so
it still says crochet sweater in the
title though is that okay but here it
says machine knitted crochet style
sweater we updated that it didn't say
handmade but yeah
I mean I see what you're saying though
it's a crochet style yeah
what's your problem with robots why
what's with the anti-robot sentiment
here they're people they have feelings
too you know how we get the uprising
you start with the robot racism and next
it ends up with your head on up
on a burner or something you end up as a
battery I don't know yeah all right so
here's everything
here's xqc and let me show you what a
idiot loser this guy is either
so he turned he turned on this guy Vince
vintage yeah obviously obviously when we
were like people don't come out against
you because they're afraid that you're
gonna on them which he proved to be
100 right said your giant piece of
for this is exactly why people don't
complain when you steal their video scum
I was actually super angry because I was
like I I talked to Vince he came out in
good faith and I just felt bad now he's
being dogpiled it's just like it's so
up dude
just pay him
oh and by the way the BTS on this is
so Vince is talking to the editor
and they're not they're trying not to
give him the 10x now they go you have to
provide proof that you got damaged up to
10x
oh so now he needs to prove stuff that's
not how they phrase this I said 10x to
anybody I stole yeah and now he's
bitching out while he loses a million
dollars in Vegas like nothing what a
piece of dude that's true
it's true did you say that or was that a
sound bite I did so I was agreeing with
the observation that he's blowing money
in Vegas like yeah nothing Well nickel
and diming this guy yeah
um yeah he sucks he's an uh he
didn't even talk to him he sent him to
talk to his editor
he might even have made his editor fall
in the sword and pay him from his own
Revenue like he is a giant tool
man
anyway that's all uh
I'm just speculating on the details of
that but here's the where it gets really
funny so he goes
he responds he says wait a minute you
said he didn't complain because he
doesn't want Twitter drama he's so dumb
I literally can't converse with him like
I was gonna respond to this but I'm like
getting a flashback to the conversation
we had and it's like oh you don't
understand like basic like basic
like I I mean except the building
constructive but just a white within the
community
is that where I cut him off
and said wait hold on let me read that
or is that no that's previous from him
you know when he was here on the
interview though I could understand him
completely me too I did I did so does he
sometimes like
exaggerate his I think I don't know I
think he has moments
you know
he has moments of clarity
so um
he says you said he doesn't complain
because he doesn't want Twitter drama
but yeah dude that's what you're doing
right now dumb
also he was just giving a statement to
me then he posts a leaked DM
in an attempt to make people believe a
lie okay leaked DM like you're really
pushing that this is an unanswered DM
from two days earlier bro this is a
leaked yeah that's so up that
doesn't count as a league DM leak DM you
didn't even answer him dummy and by the
way if I was xuc and I actually cared
I'd be like
I'm just right off the phone to paying
him exactly if I actually cared about
people
um
so he yeah so he's mischaracterizing
this and I hate to say it but some of
his fans are eating this up and turning
on Vince which is not surprising you
know it's somebody with a really large
audience they're gonna first take his
side I feel like you know well it's but
he really is just a mean person I'm
understanding that he actually just
really is a mean nasty person says I
simply reply to prove
that what he said isn't true yet I'm the
bad guy
huh simply reply
to prove that what he said isn't true
yet I'm the bad guy
that just mean
how is what uh Vince saying isn't true
oh I guess it's a quote tweet of this
I'm missing some content so he tags him
this guy Vince vintage
praised misketh for doing the exact same
thing I did but flips it on me only when
the tie turns first of all liar he
explained in the message why he
called you out specifically right
because he said at least the other
streamers clouded me up gave me credit
you know what I mean you specifically
ripped him off and didn't give him any
credit scumbag remember when he said
that
then he blatantly lies in a tweet
because I didn't respond to his dm with
within 12 hours liar was two days I was
flying two from Texas to La three hour
flight
yet he yet we had sent him an email two
days before misleading again
he sent it to his like work email
not his personal email or like his the
email for his managers I have a
suggestion maybe Mr xqc needs to hire
more people if you're on a flight and
you're unable to answer maybe you need
somebody else to be able to answer for
you you know like a business because
you're making so much money you can
afford it also what is he broke Wi-Fi on
the plane broke
this is what he posted by the way
as he was bitching out Vince
and refusing to pay him the 10x this is
what he's posting on Instagram uh-huh
1.1 million down
with I guess what is that 30 000 in cash
what is that what is this 1.3 million
dollars that's so crazy
I can't imagine I remember doing that
how like
your brain has to be so decayed to post
something like this
he's not you're not even a rapper like
you're why are you doing this
you just look like a man
like he
he actually is obsessed with money
and it's sad
you know well he makes so much money so
easily
you made me defend this dude sorry well
here's where it gets interesting okay
says what am I supposed to do let let
him lie down and damage me and then he
said to me ratio plus l
okay
this was taken from last night or this
morning it's been several days 3 200
likes
mine has none mine has 17 000. what
happens what happens now
um I feel like
something has to happen he ratio held me
and he lost by like four times yeah what
do you think
you know what I mean I do get what you
like the ratio did not happen where is
the police you can't just say that the
ratio police needs to come in
I agree something has to happen
I think you should give you the 100
million
I mean there needs to be some public
um
you know uh humiliation for this here
here's the ratio check right now live
wait it doesn't
it didn't open did he delete it
did he delete the failed ratio
oh maybe it's the wrong way
there hold on it's like he he literally
can't stop getting
absolutely destroyed by me this week
it's like he loves it
um he's going to start he's going to
start calling me Daddy I've been
whipping his ass so hard
uh in a sexual fetish way not in like a
child abuse way
a 17 400 right
three thousand it's like bro what are we
doing here we something needs to be done
yeah you
know not even close give him a Pity like
bro you up right now no I'm not
logged in oh maybe I'll quote tweet it
there needs to be some consequences to
this it's like
about burning the witch you know we need
some goddamns like public shaming like
this person tried to race you know it
did not happen you know and the Twitter
trending page like there needs to be a
little section for like
defeated ratio we need an uh uh forgive
me for this analogy but it's like me too
but for Twitter ratio elves
[Music]
it's time something's done about this
you know people are getting away with
horrible things and it's just not right
it's just we need more awareness so cam
can you make some kind of um
of an edit including showing his ratio
okay and then my ratio and something
that I can you know post
sure to show the world
well you better be because this is
important yeah this is there's a heavy
uh
this is a big pressure right now because
what if I lose the ratio dude
oh my goodness look at what hair do wow
what product reviews bro commercial it's
alive it's actually it's actually just a
skunk I put on my head
I see that main flowing like a stallion
and full Sprint all right I'll try and
get to ferocious strong powerful thank
you very much masculine
[Laughter]
I like to ride that
I'm gonna eat you like a like a dollop
of peanut butter
easy cowboy
sorry Cameron it's okay no I appreciate
them you look good you look good thank
you you look great
but yeah I'll get in the ratio shot for
you yeah so
I don't know if a new Banner gives them
too much but we do need to post this so
that he gets publicly humiliated for
this absolutely heinous crime but this
is what he should be probably suspended
on Twitter yes seven day suspension
somebody should can anybody post a
community notes maybe we could put
Infinity notes explaining this ratio was
failed therefore it is not an L I love
that how do you do that I don't know how
to do it I don't know
do you know how to do that you got to be
part of it I think I think you have to
be a Neo-Nazi to get into the program
I think this is a project Elon would
care about if you want to do it at him
okay if anybody in the audience is able
to do community notes
if anyone ever needed it it's this tweet
right here yeah we need like a board of
Shame just so we can shame him right
somehow he's gonna have to spend a week
on threads shame
yeah also uh
this tweet was kind of insane too he
said in response to his original one
calling out Vince you thought I'd stay
silent and let the storm pass oh my God
but everyone jumped on the bandwagon and
it's currently spreading lies I'm coming
for you he's just insane by the way your
first response didn't even ratio me you
oh wait no this is a response to
himself
whatever still didn't really show me
I can't believe him yeah I don't know
how he's got like such an aggressive
vibe
and again you have to and take it all in
in context I mean we get similar live
views to him I don't have a hundred
million dollars you know why it's
because I don't work with Shady crypto
unregulated gambling
that's why if I did I'd be as rich as
him maybe even richer you know what I
mean crypto
and guess what I still wouldn't be
wearing a dog also put money back into
the show and hire people and you know
make sure there's actually quality
control and like you don't just steal
content and all that stuff right
and you don't have one person making
thumbnails and like right
because he was like oh we're only two
people can you imagine if I like
re-uploaded someone's video and they're
like yo can you can you just pay me the
revenue like yeah message love uh it's
not my problem yeah just hit up love
love will pay you out of his own money
yeah I got it 10x out of 10 extra 10x
these nuts dude them yeah I got it
yeah he sucked he actually sucks so bad
and uh
oh God this is from his own subreddit
yeah it doesn't have any elbows but I
just thought it's funny to see the first
two hours how it was going this is from
the first two hours where he still had a
chance frankly yeah we live in an era
where xqc tries to ratio h3h3 and fails
well I don't know what era you think it
is but I feel like that's been a
this has been we've been in the long era
yeah this is like the the Chi Dynasty
okay we've reigned over this for
thousands of years yeah
xq who
excuse see these nuts in your mouth
right that's spicy got him
I love when I see his own subreddit
everything on fire thank you guys thank
you
he did however drop a major Expose and
this is the last thing I'll say about
that major exposure
so he promised
he he was panicked when um
he saw his ex
had emailed me um
in fact he was messaging me all day in a
panic trying to get me to tell him what
was in it oh I said no bro I'm not
getting involved
legit he's like can you just tell me if
it said this in it I was like I'm
not playing wow I'm not playing hot or
cold with you I swear to God he was in a
full-on panic and like he's such a
scumbag pretty interesting read this
he's like in a full-on panic dude
oh yeah dude he goes he goes you need to
read me the email she sent you
he says that counts as hate mail doesn't
it because I said I don't I read I read
unsolicited hate mail
I was like not to me dummy
yeah what did he really sit yeah he said
that here at elope don't read it out
loud but I want you to read it it's so
dumb you're just trying to get
you on a technicality
well actually you said this um actually
uh you a little hypocrite yeah
oh my God
here
okay here read from there
honestly I don't have I don't owe him
anything not to read them publicly but
we'll see what you think about them I I
don't have to you know what I mean
so here's the exposed um
he he tweeted this out
a few days ago yesterday actually
tonight or tomorrow afternoon I'm gonna
leak it all there's too many lies that
are floating around and before this
becomes a massive game of telephone I
owe it to you guys and myself to clear
up what the is actually going on
finally were you bored of those I mean
don't actually well I can't talk about
it so I don't want to like yeah I don't
want to have it in my brain if I can't
talk about it so here he goes everyone's
been waiting for this
here goes late one night in 2021 I was
at a restaurant in Los Angeles and I saw
a man in the booth arguing with the
waitress
she asked him to leave
and as he was already trespassing for
previous transgressions that was her
words
and in response he began screaming
suddenly the air became dense and a
smell I can only describe as putrid
wafted
my way oh my God it was clear that the
man had either soiled himself or was
blasting serious uh gas
[Music]
cops wearing respirators arrived to
remove the man he began to fight with
them too
as they dragged him out of the Denny's I
caught a glimpse of his face that man
was Ethan Klein
[Music]
I knew it because I knew it dude it was
a good troll I was there too you
Gaslight all of us I was that's first of
all this is Fanfare I was there I've
never been to Denny's by myself I wrote
that I've literally never been to
Denny's by myself in my life
I probably went to denny's like three
times in my life
one of them was yeah no and a night on
2021.
the accident
why does that sound like Aiden Ross
I can hear that you don't know who that
is let me hear it again
oh I think I know who it is I know who
it is
who is it
not the Wally expert you guys are you
guys are you guys are more invested I am
pretty invested all right let's thank
our one sponsor real fast and then we'll
move on we'll take this call with uh
John from Portugal the Man and then
we'll get into our wonderful uh donut
daddy sketch which is going to be
fantastic exciting I did my first thirst
trap ladies and men whoever it is if
your significant other is in the room
you might want to cover their eyes
so once you get a snack of this donut
Daddy
you ain't going back
okay
others food I don't know if I can let
you air this sketch well
you're gonna realize what you have
finally thank you everybody to Shopify I
love
love Shopify hell yeah Teddy fresh from
day one has been on Shopify and that is
one of the single best decisions we've
made with this business because
it's amazing and it's easy to use for
beginners me and Ela have zero
experience building websites and we were
able to create that shop in a functional
way with products accepting Pro credit
cards and processing
then from there
it has the tools it has the plugins it
has the support it has the network to go
from
day one
we don't know anything to now you know
we have a team we have programmers
that we've been able to add the tools we
need hire programmers that specialize in
Shopify they're all in this network
super easy to find them and you can
build an Empire I'm not saying we have
an Empire but there are Empires on
Shopify it's just it's the best
e-commerce platform I I can't say it I
can't say it enough I love that they
have games that you can choose and use
them and we've we've over the years for
example chose different teams we had to
change at some point and they make it
super easy you can make a draft theme
before you make it public like they make
everything so intuitive and so seamless
we've never had any issues right and
then which says a lot never dude we've
our website has never been down that's
crazy that's another thing you have to
worry about especially as like an online
personality because everybody's always
trying to with you yeah
foreign
never been down
go ahead everybody try to overload our
site wow look how sad I am
come on millions of you guys go on the
website
and take a look around too while you're
there
um
yeah they also have templates that you
can buy from like high level uh web
designers and then they'll help you
implement it yes or you can hire a web
designer to edit one of their uh
templates it's it's you can do anything
with the website I mean
I loved it I love them so much and I'm
just a huge huge fan so
uh yeah there's no joke really I don't
know why it says that man there's no
jokes here
uh listen
if you wait if you make
right
[Music]
okay
I'm gonna move past this part
whether you're a garage entrepreneur IPO
ready Shopify is the only tool you need
to start run and grow your business
without a single struggle
Shopify puts you in control of every
sale Channel whether you're selling
satin sheeps
or you need their POS system or you're
selling organic olive oil I mean sake it
doesn't matter
shopify's it's an all-in-one e-commerce
platform
once you've reached your audience
Shopify has the internet's best coveted
checkout to help you turn them from
browsers to buyers that's true they have
like really good job pay
the shop pay is amazing but they have
built-in features where like they'll
send email to people who left items in
cart you know yes and you can customize
the whole thing really good like stuff
like that is
[Music]
high level stuff if you're building it
from scratch but you can do that
immediately
yeah
um
[Music]
yeah no matter how big you want to grow
Shopify gives you everything you need to
take control and take your business to
the next level they got a deal going
guys
shuffle my Powers 10 of all e-commerce
in the US holy smokes
good for them
not surprised they power all birds
rothies Brook linen and Teddy fresh
across 170 countries these guys know
what they're doing
sign up for one dollar per month trial
at shopify.com after dark all lower case
go to shopify.com after dark
to take your business to the next level
two day one more time shopify.com slash
After Dark Link is in the description
thank you so much to our sponsor Shopify
and consider supporting them if you're
in the business too if you're in the
business of business
am I right
[Music]
I really do love Shopify me too
I can't recommend them enough okay this
is interesting this this is compelling
okay so ratio denied you're a weirdo
plus your watch is trash
so this is a lot yeah work with me on
this one Kim I don't know and work with
what I'm giving you told me it should be
like me too oh no no no no no you don't
need to do that it's like why is it okay
yeah I don't know either I didn't know I
mean I like you did good with what you
had okay I misinterpreted what direction
dude Olivia you're the Dog Whisperer
look at this she's always with oh afraid
you'll lay under my desk it's the cutest
thing in the world how cute it's so
sweet Alfredo such a good boy he makes
the cutest little cuddle noises
it does he really does he's like when
when you're scratching and cuddling it
sounds like he's like can't breathe it's
like an oink he's like
and usually he breathes fine yeah
all right so so we'll work on another
one cam a version two uh we don't need
the me too I just want it to be really
clear that his ratio was denied
got it mixing making him the ultimate
loser got it got it got it okay I'll get
back
you know maybe he could be in like one
of those public vlogging things where
his hands and neck do you think that's
good sure because he needs to be
humiliated in the Public Square got it
they were lock him in this and people
throw tomatoes at them and stuff I don't
know if that might look too aggressive
yeah
okay fine just do a Gallow
just kidding that's a joke okay no no
nothing like that I'll figure it out
yeah thank you all right let's bring on
John he's uh in the lobby all righty
standby the front man
for Portugal the Man yeah his name is
not Portugal oh
oh in the stew he's in the stew
always in this dude
hello hello
hey what's happening nice to meet you
John first of all
uh thank you for taking care of our boy
[Music]
[Applause]
he shredded man
I gotta be honest man I was
that's surprised by the The Shred but uh
he definitely brought it thank you John
that was so love you man also what a
Class Act this guy is he left the stage
yeah to give the spotlight to Zach I
mean what a Class Act people come on
give me a break that's so generous yeah
you know I saw uh Megadeth in Alaska
back in the day
and one of the uh it might be the
craziest performance I've ever seen this
dude
he he gives the band a moment so this is
like one thing I saw gives a band a
moment guitarist is shredding and we
really should have done this but
guitarist is shredding Dave Mustaine
comes out he's actually been shredding
the whole time guitarist takes his hands
off the guitar it's been Dave's moment
it was never the guitarist moment that's
awesome
yeah Zach has it for sure so uh how are
you
uh doing all right my daughter was sick
last night so I'm on no sleep right now
oh no I'm sorry to hear that yeah I was
hearing a little bit about uh or reading
a little bit about
this condition your daughter has one in
six in the whole world I mean Jesus it
doesn't get rarer than that does it
yeah I think with uh genetic testing I
mean just like the nature of it is
you're gonna find that there's a lot of
one in six oh interesting okay I I think
that's just like
so what comes with her her disease is
like it's Parkinson's it's like
Alzheimer's dementia with kids
essentially and it would I think it
would have just been put under that
umbrella back in the day well you said
it's like Alzheimer's dementia and kids
yeah oh my God so it's like
neurodegenerative
um Progressive I mean the main things
that we see are like it's cognitive
stuff you know
like her attention spans really pretty
short oh my God I'm so but uh my heart
goes out to you man yeah it's so hard
dude she's cool as hell man like it's uh
it's been pretty like you know we we
bring her out on stage with us every now
and then like if we're home like she
can't really travel with us a ton
but when she comes out it is the coolest
I've ever seen like she she gets
out she goes are you ready to rock are
you ready for Portugal the Man and you
know she did something that was so sick
like she came on stage here in Portland
and she was pointing at people out in
the audience she was going I see you I
see you I see you oh my God man how old
is your daughter
she just turned 12. oh 12. did you have
any other kids
no just just Francis and France and so
do you mind if I ask you I'm curious
about
the kind of stuff she's been going
through do you mind if I ask you
questions about it for sure of course so
like when did you guys start noticing I
guess symptoms of some issues
so I guess it was around like three
years old she
um it was just that she wasn't the I
guess the average kid yeah she was she's
just different you know
and we took her in for evaluations we
couldn't really figure it out and then I
think about three years ago she started
having seizures
and like just one of our friends noticed
they were like yo she's like she fell
down a few times and we tried to catch
it took her into the you know doctor and
none of it showed itself
so Zoe um
her mom started uh just documenting
everything and she went from like she
was having a few seizures a day to yeah
it was really really fast started having
every 10 minutes she'd have these like
absent seizures
which uh they kind of get misdiagnosed
as behavioral issues
she just zones out for a second
okay yeah so if you're like hey Francis
and she doesn't look at you kind of just
looks like attention Okay but uh yeah
she started falling down like a lot
and uh man those medications for
epilepsy are brutal she started taking
different medications and like Depakote
I'm sure you'll hear like all kinds of
stories about this but she started
taking Depakote and
it's just crazy like she doesn't have a
big vocabulary
and uh they were saying one of the side
effects that she's going to talk about
death
and why would Francis ever I've never
known France was to talk about that she
just doesn't
and yeah sure enough like two weeks in
she's like yelling at me every day it's
pretty it's pretty I mean it's just a
really intense thing like seeing like
wow wait little kids deal with this
stuff like I had a you died she started
saying that to me like you died I'm dead
how is it that a medicine has a side
effect of talking about death what the
that is so bizarre
yeah well I mean I think that's I mean
it's kind of like the
the beauty of modern medicine as well is
that I mean it's down to that much of a
science that they know I mean it's
good good to kind of have it in your
pocket so if you see this uh take her
off of it so you guys took her off that
specific medicine
yeah and the the meds she's on right now
the it's it's like working working she
did uh lamitra Jean and Lamictal and
her seizures are not as severe
yeah I mean she still hasn't so she was
she was sick yesterday with like
something else she had just a flu
and she was just out all day and I
noticed when she came to she was
um she gets these migraines and she was
kind of covered up all day and she still
has them like she has like absence
seizures so she like disappears for a
second but I mean when she's there she's
popping man
[Music]
and so
the first three years of her life you
guys she was like any typical baby
reaching all the developmental marks and
stuff
yeah I mean for the most part
um so she toured with us so she was out
on tour with like
12 to 16 people all the time so it's
pretty difficult to gauge the like when
did she walk because somebody for the
crew had always pick this kid up and uh
yeah she seemed to seemed to hit
everything I mean she
I mean that's kind of like the scary
thing about it is you're if you're
watching it I see her Tremors get worse
you know I saw the epilepsy come on I it
just took a while to figure out what it
was
um but yeah I mean thank God for genetic
testing and and the fact that we saw
what it was I mean this this scariest
moment honestly was
it's a relief to know that somebody has
an idea of what it is
um but the six months that it took for
us to get somebody to explain it to us
was it was it's so brutal because
there's six kids in the world they exist
in they live in China and Italy we can't
get a hold of any of those families so
we're just zoeing our in different
places at at the time like I'm recording
she's home
and we're reading about this and I mean
it's pretty pretty scary like you're on
a WebMD for six months waiting for the
breakdown
what dude I'm
I mean this as a
me and Eli have young kids now you know
so
I can only imagine just damn man
what was it like as she aged like what
kind of symptoms did she manifest as she
went from like diagnosis at three until
like now she's 12.
well she she got diagnosed at night like
nine and a half oh okay okay I guess so
she started showing symptoms at three
and then you guys didn't even know what
it was until she was nine
yeah I mean people mentioned a Tremor
she is she has like issues with like
muscle she can't really um
do the same things as most kids I mean
the things that I noticed along the way
were like she loved hiking and she can't
hike anymore
you know and and that's it's sad to see
things like that kind of go but she
becomes interested in other things she
loves cooking and like
I think it it was just the epilepsy I
mean that's like a really
let us know that something bigger is
happening
oh yeah
yeah I think dude she's she's cool man
yeah thank you it's so much like she
loves wearing Teddy fresh like she's
feeling so cool yeah like this kid like
yeah she she's been loving all of that
stuff so it's cool seeing her go in and
pick out her own outfit
and I feel really cool
that's awesome that's really cool so um
well any so you're in do you live in LA
where you guys live
no we're in Portland OR outside of
Portland okay Portland so are you guys
uh on tour regularly or yeah I know you
guys were just out here in LA
yeah usually I mean we're usually out
but um this summer it's been pretty
chill mainly the Francis stuff so we
kind of did like this handful of of
bigger shows
and dude honestly Zach coming up was it
was so fun I was originally reaching out
to him about samples because he does so
many funny like drops like we we were
kind of incorporating things like that
into the set and it's so funny that that
like him playing at the Roxy just popped
up in my feed I was like yo you kind of
shred
and I I cannot thank you enough John I
mean that was the most amazing
experience of my life
oh it was fun as hell
um Charlie Day man we got Charlie Day
Weird Al is that right were they there
yeah they were the sweetest people like
everyone was just the most amazing
kind-hearted people yeah that's awesome
I met weirdo once I've I didn't really
talk with him though but I've heard he's
uh
a treasured soul
you know seriously like nicest dude I've
ever met like if that you write Al and
he is back within five minutes and uh
yeah he's he's great we did we did a
song together
um a few years ago like a serious song
oh really
yeah we did that and then we did he
remixed some of our music too which I
think getting that budget through with
Atlantic Records now not the easiest
thing right to get a Weird Al remix but
it's so sick it's my favorite thing
we've ever done that's awesome I
actually just because we were talking
about your daughter I know you have this
GoFundMe that I want to support can you
it says Francis changed my life our
search for a cure uh did can you explain
basically the
yeah so we're actually partnered with a
uh a foundation uh and Lauren which
helps fund research for these rare
diseases and um
dude this was like a the heaviest thing
to me was when they told us what it was
okay we need to develop Asos genetic
therapy Gene therapies and we need to
develop a treatment for Francis
and so and I go okay cool let's sell the
house let's let's do all like everything
we can and I mean the response from the
doctor was like oh no it's not that
simple it's it's not like money like
it's not money that you have
um just thinking about the other
families that that deal with these rare
diseases and
um just genetics I kind of just our
whole goal is to further the research
uh further the science to lower the cost
for families families in the future
so it's it's really just like we're
trying to put everything we can into
getting people to get on like do genetic
testing it's the easiest thing I mean
it's so simple now and it's really
accessible
just to know
I see that every day like on the on the
street like I see
Francis you know I look around I go
a lot of these people are probably
dealing with a lot of the same things
and nobody knows what it is right yeah
so when you say and they'll never be
tested when you say get genetically
tested do you mean like
if you're experiencing something to
figure it out or are you curious would
you be curious if you were a carrier or
would you even know if you were a
carrier
yeah exactly so a lot of these
um genetic mutations they they kind of
show themselves later in life as well
so working with and Lauren
um this foundation will will help fund
for anybody like it's there's there's no
like status to it like it's
go and apply and they will help you try
to develop these treatments
um
it's
they have a patient there that's like 60
years old
and and their their genetic mutation
showed itself later in life uh Zoe and I
both got tested to see if we were
carriers of this just to check and we
weren't wow yeah these can just pop up
wow wow
well uh the the GoFundMe by the way it's
in the pinned in the description I'm
definitely gonna donate to it
oh I gotta tell you man
now that I'm a father it's like
nothing I don't think anything upsets me
more than like seeing children
suffer mm-hmm
it's just
it's just not right
should just never happened
you know
they're like just so pure of soul and
innocent it's like
it's just so I don't know it shouldn't
happen
and the parents too you know
but you guys look really strong
you're smiling all the time do you have
faith are you are you a religious guy
no I would not say so but
um I do love Francis and she is
she's just so fun to hang out with like
go out with and
see how she like interacts with people
how much is all kids
it's pretty hard like having kids and
looking at adults like I just see little
kids everywhere like that is the kids
everywhere I go
and maybe it's the world that I work in
but
I do believe
um
I do believe things happen for a reason
all right I do believe I I was given
Francis and
I think that's a really powerful thing
and I I feel so lucky to have what we
have like I
like I said I can't I couldn't imagine
like imagine being a parent who was
working two jobs or three jobs and
your kids having seizures they say oh
let's do genetic testing oh it's this
thing it's going to be 20 million
dollars
how do you process that so wait what was
the 20 million for
just the cost over like a lifetime
really wait wait wait you've spent that
much no no no we haven't we're in the
process of raising the money and
um working with and Lauren to develop
treatments the cost of developing these
drugs is extremely high right now I see
I see just because it's so new the
science is so new yeah yeah that the
cost is is very high and the more we get
through families like Francis and other
families around the the lower that cost
goes
I it does sound like it would be like
extremely expensive too because I know
how up our Health Care system is
to you know care for a child with so
much particular needs I can I mean
I can imagine that's probably been
another thing you guys been dealing with
yeah uh yeah that that was that was the
whole thing like not being silly and I
immediately were like we have a pretty
big song dude I feel pretty successful
and to look look around and go like oh
we can't even pay for this like we
can't sell things and pay for it
and uh yeah the doctors were like keep
her in the home like keep things as
stable and as consistent as possible and
like find people like Anne Lauren help
fund and lorem and these foundations
that that search for uh cures for these
diseases search for treatments I mean
the real goal is like
these these bigger treatments and these
cures are like 10 years out five years
ten years out so you're like trying to
delay the way it affects Francis so you
don't want to it to progress too far so
that when you say it's like a I guess do
you know what these drugs will do that
they're developing
if they're not developed yet so they
don't know what's the benefit or what or
it is they're just testing stuff
yeah so I mean they're they know that
these
um these treatments work
they've seen them work I mean that's
just the nature of like this uh getting
approval in our Healthcare System takes
time and it takes a lot of families
getting tested to get that approval and
getting those drugs through they know
these drugs work but they can't I mean
they really can't say with
um certainty like if it will work for
Francis you know it's worked for other
kids
so wow that's frustrating too just
waiting for that
yeah I mean I obviously that's the
hardest part well anyway what's for
dinner tonight
hey uh thank you guys for talking about
that I did I did not expect to be
jumping on And discussing Francis and
she is my favorite subject and uh
yeah dude uh
thank you guys for what you do oh you
guys do such such cool things cool
and
yeah I appreciate you giving us Zach for
the the evening yeah you I I lend him
out from time to time
so John I mean you're you're a fan of
podcast
um who's your favorite cast member
oh favorite why would you ask that Dan
well he has to say that kids dude
yeah we're all kids bro you can't pick a
favorite right right right right sick
but you had to choose one are you a fan
though you you watch regularly
tell them that podcast yeah yeah
yeah
I I just I just have to say something
about John he is like the coolest guy he
played the ball he flies home and then
like I'm talking to him and he's like oh
dude I'm at a minor league baseball game
right now like he's been on the roll
he's non-stop dude I love it it's bad
yeah I mean yeah let's be real dude
we gotta support Portland Sports hell
yeah you know what John dad's
rule
okay
that's right that's what I say to all my
dad friends
that solidarity and Dad good dad unite
you know what I mean we're out here
that's right Lena are you there
I'm here you can you donate five
thousand to the GoFundMe
from your personal money okay yeah no
not from us from you
I'm on it now and you got yeah if anyone
else is interested
yeah I mean it may be like what's the
deal I thought we were coming to the
show
they were away yeah I yeah we were in uh
Arizona for the weekend and we were
rushing back
um without saying too much uh we were
with family and having some family drama
but we really wanted to be there you
know we've been fans of you for a while
and of course we want to support Zach as
well so we were very upset we'll be
there for the next one
yeah we were really bummed we really
wanted to go
well listen if it makes you I maybe it
feels better none of us went to see
Oliver tree and we're like fairly well
acquainted with him you know that was
actually my first concert ever pretty
much
yeah I don't go to yeah we didn't talk
about that oh was never crazy
like well in general I don't like being
in crowded places it's like I have to
it's from the Swedish Countryside
and well I liked it a lot it was really
really cool yes you're gonna hate the
future ones where you just get a ticket
and you have to go like on yeah like a
pleb Loser yeah
yeah
um
what are you guys working on bandwise
uh we just put out a record so we just
put out um Chris black changed my life
um probably working on new stuff touring
quite a bit
I guess we'll probably try to pop down
for Sac San Diego show of course oh
good shout out let's go appreciate that
buddy so that's the name of your guys's
new album I'm trying to look it up here
yeah it's Chris black changed my life
which is also tied to France has changed
my life though this just came out in
June
yeah it just came out so the whole thing
is
our friend Chris toured with us uh he
was like our MC people call him like our
hype man he was just like our friend uh
just to be on your side I don't really
like crowds of people either like it's I
get anxiety being on stage it's
it's weird that I ended up playing music
but I I just love being around
passionate people and Chris Chris was my
buddy that like took all that weight off
of me he like loved attentions who'd
come out and he would dance and he'd be
like everybody look at me you know and
just mess around and the album is about
talking about friends of ours like I
wish I had told him a lot of things well
he was alive he passed away a few years
ago and
uh he really did so much for me and
so Chris Chris black changed the band's
life helped us see things differently
France has changed my life personally
it's it's really just about talking
about people around us who changed our
lives and
uh really it's been kind of sick like
organically in comment section seeing
people shout out their friends
oh Jeff changed my life and Jeff jumps
in it's like that's crazy dude I'm
looking the the reviews I'm seeing
online are great so you guys should
definitely go stream download
you know what I'm saying Chris black
changed my life
yeah
it's family this is Family Music now
um
wow
well uh it was really
um great to connect with you and kind of
learn about your story and everything
and yeah
I feel like people like you guys are
really inspiring just to see you going
through something like that
and being so strong I'm sorry
she's pregnant
I thought I could hold it
yeah no I get teary-eyed listening to
that I mean
there's a story I want to tell you but
it's kind of dark but I always find it
interesting I'm not a religious man
either you probably know that if you
watch
but uh it was like I forget who wrote it
but they says that
they don't believe in God and the reason
why they don't believe in God
of all the terrible things that happen
in the world you know that people do to
each other
but the one thing that like uh
does not make sense to him is like when
bad things happen to kids
because like
like I was saying they're innocent they
haven't hurt anybody
all they need is support and nourishment
and like if there is a God
and I know like religious people say
like you know this happens for a reason
that happens for a reason it's all God's
plan
but
and he was saying and I agree there's
nowhere in God's plan
where kids suffer
that uh
is acceptable for in any God's plan you
know he said a lot more poetically than
that but I always I always remember that
story and
it really is the hardest thing man
it's the one thing that gets me
since becoming a dad
how's your wife doing are you married
yeah yeah yeah
uh I mean it was pretty pretty tough
like you're just seeing all of this
stuff and not knowing what it was uh
it's definitely
brought us together like
tackling the whole thing you know taking
it on it's
pretty
it's pretty heavy being around such like
a
fun kid but Zoe is like the expert she's
like the leading expert on dhdds Wow and
that's what I mean the parents chef of
those kids I mean yeah you become the
expert you have to there's there's not
enough of them around to
put resources in that basket
you know
sorry go ahead
yeah no it's it's been really inspiring
for me being around her and watching her
just endlessly like consume all of this
these research papers and
um
have you guys ever thought about it if
you'll you're gonna have more kids
uh uh
am I putting you on the spot yeah yeah
hands are full
yeah Francis Francis is everything
Francis is like five kids yeah she is
she's pretty wild by the way thank you
to Lena ayad who donated five thousand
dollars on behalf of Ethan
says it says Lena
but that's right under it says donated
on behalf just because of my account
it's all it allows me to do well it's
about the money not about the credit
right Lena or I mean right uh Ethan I
mean right uh
John
um
yeah thank you guys
well you guys this means a lot
those are heroes
absolutely
well listen let's stay in touch
you know
yeah yeah definitely I'll give you some
updates I'll send you some Francis
videos yeah that'd be awesome
so uh guys this is important Chris black
changed my life go stream it in fact go
to like Best Buy
and all the phones and stream it there
that's probably not helpful
go to the Apple Store open it there set
it on autoplay no I don't know the album
is incredible it is going to be like top
of my Spotify rap this year so yes
please go listen to it it's nice nice
[Applause]
good dude
thanks for calling it's nice to connect
with you
and thank you teddy fresh absolutely
thank you you're so welcome well we got
to keep it coming yeah I know she likes
it yeah
absolutely all right well
um I'm gonna go a donut now
[Laughter]
so I don't know if you're gonna stick
around for that but uh that's what's
gonna be coming up next
yeah we'll watch from home yeah
John I I just want to say thank you
again brother it was absolutely amazing
dude of course thank you there's nothing
I love more than just throwing somebody
on the stage and being like
good luck
rehearsal no rehearsal
that was just Rock and Roll Baby amazing
yeah blow you up on this Zack but we did
do a soundtrack okay we did do a
soundtrack
[Laughter]
rehearsal
pull back the curtains yeah there we go
well Zach told me he hasn't slept in
three days because he's still buzzing
I'm still buzzing from the being
on stage with you guys
and listen Jackson established musician
we're talking about the Roxy I'm talking
about the Troubadour Troubadour we're
talking about the number one podcast in
the world that's right
yeah thank you for letting us come too
yeah it was appreciated very much very
cool
yeah of course thank you for coming I
love the yes covers you guys were doing
too it's a beautiful performance all
around though
oh man yeah thank you guys oh my God I
did not expect any of this
well man uh me neither actually
you know uh but I'm glad we chatted this
has been an incredible connection we've
made so thank you again and let's stay
in touch yeah okay thank you guys thank
you all right take care
well that is uh John
from Portugal the Man I wanted to ask
him now what is Portugal the Man it's
probably people probably know that I'm
just like a yeah Normie what is it
who's Portugal let's ask Chad gbt yeah
forget that's your best friend let's
listen yeah
I mean
okay here's cams okay well before I show
this what a guy I mean wow yeah
such a sweet seems like the sweetest guy
the amount of love he has for Francis is
just it's absolutely
amazing
doesn't actually say who the man is but
who's Portugal who is he
who the is Portugal
should we get him back on the phone uh
it's a a here it's a Alter Ego like
Ziggy Stardust or Sergeant Pepper it's
our character to represent us as a band
in picking a country's name it was one
name that represented a group of people
it made sense for a while but we
regretted ever since that day
with it now
[Laughter]
well dank God damn man
it's a beautiful man so appreciate him
calling John said this means so
much to me please thank the whole game
gang
he's just the biggest sweetheart in the
world
Legend thanks bro yeah it was nice to
talk to you I didn't know what I didn't
expect any of this stuff either I just
wanted to thank you for having Zach on
you know
oh yeah yeah
so much respect for him and his wife
yeah people that have to go through
stuff like that with their children it's
just I mean it's so hard on the whole
family
good that just becomes their life
and like here's the like you love them
so much and then you're always knowing
and worrying right because he says it's
a degenerate degenerative disease
meaning it gets worse over time and like
just to
to you know
obviously yeah
by the way not that this is important or
that I care but apparently they updated
it to my name oh right Lena
not that I I don't care I mean I don't
need the credit for it or anything happy
for you though I do do that Lena
[Music]
how'd you do that
it's hard for Lena to hear you over
there I'm sorry I heard
I the name for the donation oh it gave
me the option to edit I didn't see that
until after so oh that's cool you didn't
have to do that that's okay I don't care
not a big deal to me but uh I guess it
changed your back well no you don't need
to do the extra work or anything all
right
guys on behalf of the clients maybe
actually you know what uh uh not to be
like uh shoot down 5001 not to be
braggadocious or anything and yeah not
it's not in my nature to be like this
but actually uh this is me as well
anonymous
yeah
like that curb episode
oh
what a Legend dude I just want
to say it's it's not five thousand
dollars I also donated it as well I
wanted to support the cause and um
that's nice John is just the man
he's the man
there it is
are we ready for the donut Daddy
okay good
so this is very fun
to completely Segway I don't think any
of us expected to have a tear jerker
here at 2 50 p.m on Friday I thought it
was Friday as soon as you started
talking about this topic I was like
trying not to well I had to break down
because it's so hard it's so hard to
talk about it yeah and I mean Bruce is
not even two years old right like you
just don't know
and just know how much we love him you
know what I mean he's just so pure and
so innocent
and he doesn't deserve anything but like
just love and joy and happiness
this poem I don't even remember what it
was it was a short story but this guy
was like uh you know adults they've
tasted from the nectar of life
even anyone over 18 they felt they've
experienced they've they've made
mistakes they've done good things
they've they've lived a life
but like a child has not even
you know
I don't know to me that makes sense I
don't know how you can explain that and
I'm not trying to be an edgy atheist
it's just my personal opinion I don't
know how
you fit that in with this the theory of
God existing
I don't know where that fits into his
plan you know
is this good ratio denied
or loser loser this is pretty good
should we post this and tag him
not maybe can you work up another
version for us cam uh can you give me a
direction I'm out of ideas so let's more
just like more just focused on the ratio
denied
and like for Twitter like titer maybe
more of like a square okay should I get
rid of all like the text and I
think so because it's got to be visually
very like you gotta yeah you gotta be
able to look at it and then understand
this loser
got ratio denied okay I'll get back in
the shop yeah we'll keep working on it
it's okay it's a work in progress yeah
big deal it's gonna be a it's going to
be ready to go by into the show for sure
all right let's talk about daddy donut
daddy so on Tick Tock I'm so curious
there is such a variety of thirst traps
yeah I don't know if you've seen any
there's one that I've talked about the
dude who chops wood
he's like he wears overalls he just and
then like he just chops wood and the
ladies go crazy they're all like moms
you know what I mean like so sexually
like they're fantasy
oh I think even Doja cat did a reaction
to him once maybe you guys can pull that
up
of I think his name is Thor something
Bradley Thor yeah I just found it yeah
this guy I'll be honest
every time I get his videos I watch it
and not because I I find it fascinating
I genuinely find that act of like
chopping wood and like I know what he's
doing and I go to the comments and it's
always funny but I actually find what he
does pretty interesting he seems to be
quite a good uh lumberjack
at least that you know
but let's expect a good wood chop you
know that's it uh but uh here let's see
this one has three million
this dead snag of a pine tree
with nothing but this one felling ax and
a little bit of WD-40 since you guys
complained about it again right yeah
WD-40 hmm
yeah work it
work that this is important I
respect that chop that tree
I've never seen him wear a helmet
actually so this is Safety First this is
serious yeah this is going to take a
minute
oh God see how he spits in his hand no
Sean
lumberjets don't do that
this guy is gonna chop down this
tree yeah
not for Thor it only took three minutes
really
and you can feel the moisture accuracy
yeah the moisture because I'm saying
like he is actually really good
excellent yeah
and he's gonna chop this tree
down yeah oh yeah right
and um but the the comments are just
drenching big opening here my widest
point
because I'm aiming in that direction so
it's time to make that big opening
a little bit bigger
that's what I'm talking about yeah
104 or five degrees in Israel wide in my
hole
slam my whole wide open Daddy
what's with these comments it's not
showing top comments just random ones
hmm
hi oh you see that they did not need to
edit that yet that was so unnecessary
you know what I mean we want to yeah
they could have caught that and then
we'll be ready serious working outside
perfect
wow
he's gonna get it you guys this is going
somewhere no that Heartwood right now
just giving our boy Thor a shout out
switch just to be safe
Chad is going feral right now
yeah you guys are sick
shame on you guys oh
and pure thoughts we should be
we should be getting close
he switched the other he's working the
other side ladies
he's working the shaft on the other side
yeah star
you sure we don't need more WD-40 a
little more Lube no you don't need Lube
when it comes to Thor he gets you wet
this man does not need Lube
look at this that's that's pretty
skillful right wow I mean that man just
yeah yeah no doubt that's pretty badass
he is he's a wood Chopper he's done this
before
he always throws traps at the end
look at this
let me tell you one of the ones way less
that wasn't the one that one was really
bad not typical of his content that
one's for the boys
really prefer the belt removal with one
hand to the suspender removal
and I'm really gonna have to find a few
reasons to take off a belt
see what I'm saying in this one this one
is out of control
What's the storyline here smaller than
that I think he's playing into the
thirst trap thing at this moment I want
to go back to one of his original ones
he gets like this he goes he's like
oh that was hard like he said or
there's a lost Center because he talks
dirty to the wood okay here oh yeah dude
it looks like a goddamn yeah like a
torso yeah she's about to he's about to
bust that wide open I mean no
matter the type of wood
um this grain pattern is what we have
going on yeah work it off shoots of this
uh
good tree here it's gonna be a good tree
it's gonna be weird for sure
I think I might be able to get it to
split let's find out let's split that
this is his typical stuff that I've seen
he just sets up a log
and then goes to work at it busts it
open and then he goes he gets all
angry at the end too
yeah
work that Thor he always he always gets
the job done
that's right this as possible
it's possible it's tough all right
come on some there's all there's always
some haters in the comments who accuse
him of uh
being a phony Lumberjack really we're
like they're like that was was wet
it was easier there's people there you
know what I mean you can't say that
after the the uh the last video we
watched yeah the one where he chopped
down they try man they try to come for
him
same spot
get it come on yeah come on come on
don't stop a moments there oh wow it did
happen okay now watch
the do not come okay whatever so
anyway that's an example of I what I
think is it probably an acceptable
thirst trap to the point where it fell
I'm watching it it felt organic you know
yeah it wasn't try hard here's Doja cat
who um
you guys like to see me spend a little
bit more time on a piece so I found this
one
and I figured it's going to take quite a
bit of work let's find out
[Laughter]
that was only four swings boy
oh yeah that's what he does at the end
he goes that made me sweat a
little bit watch this
sweat a little right
so this is my boy uh Thor okay okay I
hope he's a good I hope he's a nice guy
in real life but not a dick right I feel
like he could be a douche in real life
but I hope not you know what I mean that
guy I have a question he could be a
total dick in real life that's the
that's the energy I get that guy
dude oh sure clearly
clearly Zach you're talking about the
women do a handstand for you guys all
right I gotta stop you're talking about
this being a thirst trap for women a lot
but what about the gays listen I
everybody's welcome
the comments that I see are like soccer
moms that are like you know just thirsty
you know
thirsty thirsty but okay so that's uh
Thor
now we're moving on
to what I think is unacceptable thirst
traps this is vile
so here is uh Cedric Lorenzen
this man does cooking thirst traps
okay so take a look at take a look at
this and we're gonna have to mute it
okay go ahead so here here it is
what is happening already it's all like
it's really well done he spit on it
I'm part of the cooking that one's
pretty good actually I've seen more
flagrant
I've seen more at what point are you
supposed to spit while making that dish
when it's time to uh rub its uh clitoris
I don't know
um why doesn't show the views so this
one's actually not the worst offender
but I'm just easing you guys in you know
here's coconut or mousse from the same
guy
see like that is just vile that's just
there's no reason for all that hold on
let me go back
coconuts and Barbados could never
oh no no coconuts are divorced
dude he straight fingered that Pokemon
why
it gets worse and worse
didn't you hear not to
cry with the shirt off
that's like number 101 dude come on
[Music]
he's good yeah so why why like that he's
got a you know he's got a um from an
angle yeah he's got it he's got an
artistic angle there here's one more
from our boy Cedric
yeah about the this dog I
mean we're not talking about him because
not with the fingers
it gets worse what are you doing bro
don't do that nobody needs dough like
that nobody nobody when have you ever
done the Shocker on a p on a doe hey
hold on go back okay here I want to see
that that Doe finger again no bro nobody
nobody
he can work his doe though
[Music]
oh yeah I had to work my dog
that looks good it does
my finger my dough that I'm
eating that cubes of chocolate
it's like uh yeah I guess those are the
pepperonis like a chocolate pizza maybe
I hit that so hard yeah it looks great
I've never seen anything like that yeah
maybe it tastes like just like
that's why nobody makes it so now we're
moving on to an even worse offender the
worst one yeah way worse
so that's Cedric he has 4.3 million
followers so these guys wow they do
quite well and like that Thor has nine
Millions
wow here's the donut Daddy
and that is his actual name
uh that's his actual name and what this
guy this guy should be in jail for what
he does
watch this
[Music]
Sunday what you see what I'm saying this
guy does too much what are you doing bro
no
[Music]
bro what the
you just took a sniff of that dose
bro
okay now the alpha music is coming on
he got the last two shots of his
forearms too
the the slapping of the dough the
forearm shots are super thirsty it knows
beautiful cinematography
yeah oh yeah yeah dude no
look at that forearm shot I don't
understand daddy daddy
okay once the cream comes out these
things go so sideways
who was it that blocked me for the cream
pie joke Markiplier yeah yeah yeah get
this video to Markiplier
at least I didn't do that that's nasty
this is not okay
food should not be combined with
sexual activity
so there's one
and uh it continues
yeah I mean look they're pretty good at
what they do yeah here he is having sex
with a mixer
we'll see how he pulls this one off
you don't need to kiss
oh
I'll just give you a big fat kiss
is this guy doing comedy I wondered
because like you think so I think this
is hilarious but it's no no no well done
but it's so well made no no not do you
think it's funny no no I think that this
is so well done there's no shot he
doesn't know that it's hilarious really
because I feel like this with the mixer
yeah
that one is kind of insane you think he
didn't like giggle after that did you
guys see that nobody commented on that
shot I missed it it was crazy bro he
comes out with the glaze
watch this it's like jerking his cake
okay here he comes with the unit after
this
bro
unacceptable
there's kids here man how about some
I think that guy is like fully
serious
well let's go to the concert she is
which she is let's go to the concert
which is which he is I feel like he's
somewhat serious the mom's in the
comments I'm crying I feel like he's
five too interesting the moms I'm crying
he has a better relationship with the
kitchen utensil than what most people
have with their love life
no one will believe me when I say I'm
here for the cinematography
I now identify as a stand mixer and it's
all ladies like this like no offense but
I just want to show you her Avatar like
that this
this is who this is who's watching this
right forget it she now identifies as a
mixer
you know he replied what are your Donuts
so like one of your guys's mom might be
in the comments here think about that
[Music]
donut yeah who's mom's in the comments
raise your hand
nobody's gonna
nobody wants their mom in the comments
but they are that's what it is Donna
might be
um no fair what's the ingredient list
here check this out
this lady that's who's in the comb you
know what I mean it looks like Donna
nope well Donna coded for sure
well not sure about that what is this
coming it looks like he can't swim
where do you guys get that it looks like
he looks buoyant so here's the last one
and this one's the most vile this is the
glazed donut and this was it this was
the sex crime this is namesake how many
followers does he have
this one has six million views oh God uh
his profile has only 250 he's he's on
the come up right now yeah that's a lot
of views though yeah he's coming up
and he's coming on
go
[Music]
did the cream pot
but is this the one we saw it was
different right it's different this is a
different one
uh the the cream pie stop I have a truck
I have a problem with don't put your
face in it he's always doing that I have
some non-garn goodbye that's
unacceptable yeah that is unacceptable
no
what
is this really really really what was
that he's not being funny there yeah
he's not enough
I don't think this guy has a good sense
of humor I think you might be right
honestly that a few of these shots are
like gross also it's like it's way too
committed like if somebody was doing it
to be funny they wouldn't make it this
well made right this is dead serious
yeah he is so serious that's crazy to me
I mean listen I've got to give the man
credit though he's good at cooking and
filming it is really well made he's
probably with everything
he's also jacked
anything else no I've covered it all
those are the only things that matter
the cream pie stuff is so nasty dude and
then watch the glazing it's just vile
I'm sorry look at that
he did not I really hated the two eggs
side by side yeah right look I hate when
he does that
bro you know what he looks like he looks
like a dude who like chews does those
jaw workouts right extremely wet so so
okay so now that I've been losing weight
you know I'm feeling myself
uh we actually spent some time for me to
explore my inner Beast
I'll give it a shot and uh here I'm
going to did you make these well I'm
planning to thirst trap
but these aren't good enough actually
um
okay
[Music]
you dirty
you about to enroll if you
ask you cream all over your face you
dirty
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
yeah so wow holy dude that was hot
and so um here it is I mean
wow wait that turned out so good yeah no
I listen I make it sexy but I also know
what I'm doing holy jalapenos
pineapple pepperoni and mushrooms oh
good infused chocolate on your lips
still
[Music]
yeah I mean so it's just food you know I
gotta say man try this pie if this
doesn't work out the podcast you have a
career somewhere else my friend oh yeah
where's that
erotic food making yeah
Ethan is the best pizza I've ever had
thank you great job there's a hair in my
mouth though oh no stop it sorry about
that I gotta say that was a lot of fun
to edit in the dark alone yesterday then
degenerate that was so good it made
Kim's Hair blow back
it rubbed off on Fabio hmm
it tastes better
when you pour the ingredients on by
humping when you finger the ingredients
first
taste better
Doug
there you go that's our submission
what'd you think bro
pretty hard Restless
yeah you know we got stuff oh yeah I
forgot I stuffed the crust too
oh you oh my god stuffed with cheese and
pepperoni
I never had one of those oh Ethan's done
it again
dude that stuff for us is everything
laughs
well
I'm just going to eat can you put on the
Papa John background
I was
that was really funny
thank you
yeah it turned out really good
uh
shout out to Ian for um
convincing me to stay yesterday to film
it
I I feel like I was too good at I had a
vision and I was a worrisome thing that
I felt good at doing it like
I was like peel peel that sausage really
get in there yeah
remove himself for a few minutes after
oh really he's getting all hot bothered
dude
okay outside I didn't watch any of it we
have a new we have a new
uh version from cam
ratio denied
Ethan 17.6 000 likes xuc 3.3 here he is
crying with an L this one is this one is
pretty good pretty good
this one's pretty good what do you guys
think
um I wonder decent maybe do we need the
actual twit in there for like the
receipt element yeah I think so
let's get another version cam
and we can do a vote maybe at the end
and then we'll launch the tweet
what do you want do you want to build
numbers you got to find a way to include
the tweets so that
you gotta show him saying L plus ratio
because if somebody sees this alone they
would be like where's the receipts what
you're re your quote tweeting that right
um
I thought that was the idea
okay that's pretty funny
the quotes with aspect is pretty good
what do we think is this that
I think the saturation's a little off
what's that the saturation maybe we
could change it a little bit
do you think xqc's face is over is over
saturated yeah something yeah I agree to
disagree on that one
but again I really know how to make a
pie this is good it's really good huh I
was hating before the show damn
did you try the crust
dude I love pregnant Ela
Turn Me Up girl I've just been like
enjoying food
pregnant ELO's the best
she's such a I don't usually enjoy food
like that I'm like yeah it's okay it's
fine whatever I hate it when you were
pregnant with Bruce I swear I gained 50
pounds
because she just enabled me anything I
wanted any time
doesn't matter how many times we ate up
oh no it's just
pure debauchery man yeah I got well what
am I you're pregnant again so I need to
keep check on myself I can't go through
that again you have been though
I've been good but you just got pregnant
yeah I still have like eight months
of pregnant Ela to uh defend against
no no way easy battle
so do we like this one as a quote tweet
I think it's perfect love it it's
perfect it's the best there's nothing
that can ever talk this well let's send
it to the audience is the text centered
Kim
uh
the ratio to nine the green green enough
on that little line yeah I don't like
the red oh it sucks
the wrong red let's do a poll is this
the perfect one or do we need more
version
okay let's do a portal like Cool Cam
about the cam
[Laughter]
well this the perfect
uh L uh yes and yes and it'll be a good
poll I am also voting yes it's so thick
the crust is like a whole meal itself
I don't think I can eat more than one
piece of that
is this how people usually enjoy food
people love pizza you know like it would
be nice to enjoy food like that all the
time people love I would be in trouble
you know what I would
happily
trade your food disposition for mine
happily if I could just walk through
life like oh I guess I have to eat now
oh I'm famished I haven't eaten I love
pizza that's my dream
it looks like um we have a winner it's
not fun though sometimes like eating
feels like a chore which is not a fun
thing I I dream of that I I'm sorry to
say it because I know it's a problem for
some people
but uh that's literally my dream
so let's check the pole we enjoy food
what do we got here I would say it's a
bad poll because Noah was an option on
that
is this a perfect ratio denied yes
the yes is winning
yeah I think we got it I think we got it
thank you guys
okay
and is this going to be cringy to anyone
outside the podcast if I quote tweet him
with this probably that's not good
either no it's not gonna be cringy it
was cringe that he said he's on a ratio
even got ratio into Oblivion
what if it said look at this
idiot on it
it pretty much does
what with the combination of the quote
tweet it could just be the top ratio
denied and then the the like statistics
yeah I like that maybe that's less
maybe that would be less cringy yeah I
mean it doesn't need to be square the
pulse said it is a perfect yeah
I want it to be I don't want peop I want
people from outside to understand what a
loser is and not be like wow this guy
cares too much it has to look like I
don't care that much have the podcast
tweeted because look how much effort
went into this I I It's gotta look
effortless right okay by the way I'm
reading the comments and it seems like
there's a pretty even split of like
people who feel like me and people who
basically say like I can't imagine
feeling that way
it's interesting I think a lot of people
go through what I do
but would you rather be an alcoholic or
somebody who
can have a beer every now and then
after my life it's not the same yeah
it's worse hates or like it's not really
dreads beer but has to have it dreads
beer but you don't have to look at the
holiday in order to be healthy you have
to have beer in order to be healthy but
you hate you direct I already shift when
you have different Health situations you
know what I mean like
when you know that you need more food
that doesn't even just eat food and have
a normal life prerogative
nope there's nobody out there
I just dropped a new effortless
updated ratio tonight
this one's not good
it's effortless
what's es meme oh I just
typo effortless do not press delete yeah
I think if we do ratio denied
there's I I'm
I gotta be frank with you yeah
there's no way to do this without it
being cringe I disagree
um but then what are we gonna do about
your denied argument with xpc it's just
it it's it's deep deep set in there like
you're opening yourself to I have I have
to respect potentially okay it's like
the movie Juice from the 90s you know
whoever whoever takes the juice from the
previous person with Tupac Ethan got the
juice now he's the juice man because he
uh he's taking out xqc it's important
Dan uh does he want to be the king
juicer yes
there needs to be consequences there you
can't just say l ratio and then
get owned right but there is a risk by
posting something like this what's the
risk it's looking dumb yeah yeah I think
the include least cringy possible way
would just be to quote tweet it and type
out wrong
um just like that was wrong not good
enough true false true let's get him on
the Gallows I don't know her
and him in front of a firing squad I
don't think that this is a captain I
think that made a good point though I
think I'm choosing to not post if if
this is an option there has to be a way
making a meme means you care I think if
that matters the the W you just got to
let it lie the W comes from the fact
that he pressed or uh posted ratio l
and then you just don't even reply
and it just never gets there that's it
that's the best thing you could do
that's how these people keep getting
away with this because we just let it
happen we just let it happen we never
say anything we just turn our cheek as
Hitler takes more and more and more land
in Europe
we say he's done we say he's done we say
it's going to stop it doesn't stop Dan
unless good people
step up to the plate
okay
just something must be done about this
bro
you can't there needs to be rules you
can't just
do that and not get called out
otherwise the whole framework
falls apart
[Music]
I'm sorry
there needs to be consequences
I mean the dude's life is falling apart
what his life is falling apart that's
Vibe just reply with question marks to
the failed rate too like foreign
nah no we're just like nah just cringe I
think God you guys are tough or you
could just write hey because he's wrong
I don't know oh how about really okay I
have an idea the meme of him with the
watch but it's but it's instead of the
watch it's his tweet a lot of effort
with 300. try hard I'm rude you can
reply just with the image no text of his
ass up in the air while he's doing the
worm
and then that gets more likes than his L
plus I like that that's the ultimate
right I I will second that down okay
send me that photo and then we'll work
on the verbiage I don't know
but then if I ratio his failed ratio
bro that's like some history right
there and xqc really cares about that
like he's gonna go into hiding no
he's totally
that's that's GT's in my dude you can't
go back on Twitch after you got L ratio
and then ratio on top of it
why is Ivermectin trending what year is
it
[Laughter]
if you Google ivermectum the very first
result comes up with a warning from the
FDA why you should never use ivermectum
to treat or prevent coven 19. what year
is is it so on Fox News
she's still they're still promoting
Ivermectin this is stunning
oh
great
all right so send me that photo
it's in Discord
oh can you send it in uh WhatsApp yep
thank you
okay perfect can I slice of pizza by the
way
once you get this right all the pizzas
are on the table in the back yeah yeah
you're not serious are you Kevin is it
all here do you need it from us no they
have a there's a ton of pizza back there
right
there's some
we might have slept cam don't ask it
makes me look like an no we left
them half a slice it's all good
people think that I'm like not I did it
I threw the whole meme
I just want to make sure people know
that policy comes from me I get fed
everybody everyone disclaimer alert I
get fed when I eat food
I sent a possible alternative response
okay send it in um like you cannot fail
with this one is it in uh WhatsApp
Discord
let me see
okay this is interesting it has never
failed me the devil gets chills when the
nice guy loses his temper I just warm a
little bit well I feel like this is too
inside our baseball yeah what would that
mean to him exactly no yeah okay so I've
got the worm image
so if we're gonna save this an
experience this gentle caress thank you
big tip I'm doing you a favor I'm
finishing your yeah hey dude I can't I
literally can't touch any more of that
is it too late
like if you reply now dude I gave him a
fair amount of time for his ratio to
pass okay so it would make sense for you
to return to it yeah
you all got over there
dude I I really wonder what are the
calories on a whole slice of that with
that cheese in the crust gotta be brutal
man yeah
but to Circle back to the Jimmy Lee meme
imagine like the exerto article and it
has this meme in it
what would they write
they probably just wouldn't
I think it's touche you know what I mean
right but what if they did what if they
did though it's a image meaning unknown
we're not sure what the podcast host
meant by this image right okay so L plus
ratio we're quote tweeting with a
picture of his ass up in the air
L press ratio
um
and then what did you say Dan
what did you say
it goes to the bathroom
dude just when I need him typical did
anyone remember what Dan said
God damn it
definitely not
Dan just what is down soundboard have to
say I can't jerk off to this
okay well it's not meant to be
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
gotta go to break I see some people say
my calorie talk is triggering I'm sorry
guys it's just
I'm on the weight loss thing and it's
what I think about
if you care about your calories
definitely don't eat Papa John cheese
crust pepperoni it's not your fault
but if you don't care honestly
thanks for letting me have some then go
to the yogurt store uh um
and get full I don't know sorry guys all
right so he said uh I don't even think
this but yeah Devil's Advocate hurry
dude you left me in the trenches bro
what did you say to write
what did you say to write on the image
oh I said nothing I said don't write
anything just the image yeah
to hit him with the worm Heil Hitler
whoa Dan that's not what the that
is the sound bite all right all right
Heil Hitler but I don't get why
man's your account Hitler
that'd be a crazy tweet
[Laughter]
and on YouTube the thing is on new
Twitter every anything goes man yeah no
do the Heil Hitler with the devil got
chills
that's confusing
a man of vision no caption just the
image
I mean my real suggestion is to not
reply at all to make that clear but if
you feel you must
something simple like that
I say no reply either
come on the world needs to know they
know they know we've been talking about
for half an hour
much difference bro it's a dub it's a
dub it's a dub you got the dub just let
it be I think we've talked about trying
to project not caring and not replying
that it's more try hard to not reply now
more try hard because we talked about
right he's right we have to reply
otherwise right
now you have to reply all I'm saying is
don't stoop down to his level that's all
I'm saying
so Hal Hitler or no
how can I swoop down to his level he's
literally on the ground because he got
the that's good okay that's pretty good
but you got the dub I stooped to your
level but I'm but you're literally on
the ground
that's actually kind of clever
it's not good right love yeah it's like
no more
face down ass up that's the way Felix
likes to get Jesus that's just
like weird
a a with no ass what'd you say
I didn't think I didn't think you said
the b word you said
whatever what are you talking about yeah
a bad that old Tick Tock yeah yeah
I'm looking at a chat one of y'all Gotta
Have a good idea some of y'all are
pretty funny
um some of y'all
yes there's people in the chat that are
super funny they're not all funny
clearly some of them are annoying
but you don't know which one I'm talking
about so if you're watching and you're
wondering you're the funny and cool one
yeah
as everyone else that's dumb and
annoying
Maybe
no reply at all
Ian debunked that already oh we did yeah
I'm with you on that one either you are
all right well I'm getting stun locked
as well I love and then I I'm getting
stunlocked I think everybody the
majority is saying nothing no reaction
I'm gonna I'm gonna wait until uh Olivia
said that too so don't you guys see that
you're enabling him you're letting him
off the hook
how we're looking out for you he's
neutered
[Music]
you can't even he can't even ratio Ethan
Klein that was good on a subreddit that
was good I gotta say
maybe that should be I'm gonna say
that's it send a screenshot from his
subreddit and I'll quote tweet with that
image that's pretty good that's pretty
good that's nice
send me the image let me think about it
someone sent me a screenshot in uh
WhatsApp
obviously I care a lot but at this point
I don't care okay because it's like I
went to a subred I'm gonna subreddit how
about this code retweet say still time
to delete it came
that's that's two I know that's what he
said but it's so cringy that that's what
he would say it's that's what xqc told
me
[Music]
okay this is pretty good
I like this one
we live in an era where xqc tries ratio
h3h3 and fails
this image is too big
okay Cam I need you to edit this
cam do you see the image in um so what I
want you to do Kim yep is move up the L
plus ratio right under my
original tweet actually here's what I
want you to do do you want it Square get
the upload get the updated likes
okay and so you show basically
my tweet of you are a giant piece of
and then make it look like he
responded
L plus ratio with the current likes got
it okay and then cut all this other
noise out so do you and do you want a
square aspect ratio what do we thought
closer to square is good right for
Twitter
69.
the worm is good because he's getting
clown okay we're gonna we're gonna keep
cooking and you want the Reddit in
there too everything correct yes that's
critical okay that's crazy part yeah got
it on it very good very good
all right
extremely wet
uh what do we got
we got Prime oh we gotta do the period
simulator love
oh
yeah we gotta bust out the period
simulator
it's time
it would be interesting to have love
debate what's a good like tweet or
thumbnail or whatever while he's having
that paint simulator I agree
I agree I'll think about it all right so
who's got the who's got the torture
device
we'll get it
we'll get it yeah what do you think
about love coming over and sitting
between you two yeah we'll pull up a
chair yeah that's cool all right because
you're gonna do it too right well we'll
do it one and then the other not this
well we only have one machine yeah I'm
gonna do it too for sure
thousand percent
I think I'm still gonna be a baby about
it
I just it just doesn't feel good you
guys I don't like when it don't feel
good
making it worse that was my only Theory
I
have like a decent pain threshold
you think I'm a total baby
[Music]
I'm not a turtle baby but I was like
performed like way worse than everybody
but when they put it on my back I went
up to the max
right but it's different
okay if you say so
we'll see what skinny Ethan has to say
about it all right love is in the
electric chair yep
Green Mile love walking down the Green
Mile
dead man walking so that connects into
like an outlet
yeah I'm like it's an outlet straight to
my stomach basically dangerous well
we've all done it yeah we've lived to
tell the tale all right it's not that
bad right I barely remember honestly
Lena was laughing yeah right
one above your belly button oh there's
just two Ian is explaining the procedure
the lift up yeah there's four of them
right yeah put put one kind of like
imagine you have a six pack it would go
like on your abs or I mean you do have a
six-pack put it on your six-pack
[Music]
got it
do you want to come over here for a
second I can apply it yeah coming on The
Green Mile Dead Man Walking
this is a Green Mile Dead Man Walking
hands of the warden he goes through with
the executions
mm-hmm
it's my job
put the man out put him
put all down let them rest
ain't no questions about his innocent
snow
sometimes there's a little question but
this time this man guilty
we've seen them with the blood on his
hands
all right here it comes the uh
the prisoner
foreign
ye who stands accused
do you have any final last words
shut up shout out
all right so I have no clue what to
expect this is very scary
and then Ian tell me where you're at and
I'll pass that information
it's not painful just like it's like
busting love you have anything isn't
that good
you're gonna have diarrhea in the last
30 days right nope okay just check yeah
it's like just warm
it's like someone is doing this super
fast
[Music]
three out of eight okay yeah that's this
is fine we can we go we can go we're
moving up to four oh yeah four oh
[Laughter]
now we that's four
do you need a Tylenol dude I'm scared to
go to Five you can do it it's like um
having like immense cramps yeah like
every month once a month shout out I I
remember the difference from there to
eight is not a bit is not a huge
difference okay well let's go to five
now going up to five oh
some twitch there a little bit that is
like crippling pain crippling pain oh
man you're doing great dude you got it
no I'm scared to go off to seven you
don't have to by all means cancel it
I dropped out love the Hot Chip is way
worse than this listen love I have
no plans to go all the way
I'm doing it again everybody it's chill
let's go to six and love is going up to
six you pop that down
okay pop it down real quick pop it down
you want it off
you don't got to prove it yeah I got
nothing to prove yeah yeah do you guys
remember what we did yeah everybody went
up no sacred the six I think oh oh but
then I went back and went all the way up
oh you did yeah I'm not going all the
way bro once you're there it's not that
different it's like feels like my uh
insides is being ripped out that's all
it's wow it's horrible it's just kind of
unpleasant
yeah I'm done I think wow yeah
yeah so do you feel uh the ladies out
there are are wondering or let's say the
those who menstruate right right to be
even more accurate
who identify or or more uh conscientious
more considerate yeah those who
menstruate out there
are wondering yeah shout out yeah
sympathy sympathy oh yeah even before
before the pain yes
thank you we're now we appreciate it's
not fair right like we have no it's
definitely not fair it's up while
we go to work and do everything and then
we go to war with our emotions yeah that
too yeah that should be free by the
way generally don't look good too like
you just feel like crap that sucks and
then you guys have to give birth which
is like even crazier once a month what's
it called bro I'm literate is it like no
like pink tax or what that should
be free there should be enough those are
literally winning incredible incredible
taste yeah all around it is pretty
insane though it's weird actually not
only is it not free feminine hygiene
products are taxed yeah exactly in
Sweden too dude it's weird why it's like
what well it's like yeah
old-fashioned also everyone's like
yo we need more babies it's like well
you could start by yeah make it
subsidizing this every that we need
every month that's expensive too thank
you guys thank you appreciate it yeah
it's Mitch McConnell's fault
all right
um so let's unplug you thank you love Oh
I thought
I thought spicy chip but it's a complete
involved having your insides ripped out
I could have probably gone up more but
it's like
it's bad it's really really bad
so I don't know should I um all right
now we have a new version uh from cam
this one's pretty good cam but the white
bar on the bottom I made a black bar too
above that
wait what go to the image right above it
there's another one
Okay one minute they give you options
wow I think you could snip the bottom
you know what I mean at the bottom yeah
and snip some off the top too good of
the white there's no be square anymore
and then I wonder if we should highlight
let's see here
should we do red boxes on here
to highlight the likes yeah
uh we can I'll give you all I'll give
you the option
yeah maybe one with one without I feel
that this is getting more embarrassed
soon the more respond more time spent on
it and
[Music]
good
I felt as soon as you tasked me with
this that it was going to be good
or maybe right here
okay
lower yeah can you move uh the gamer
stuff out from in front of Ethan yeah it
was like one above and one under the
belly button
okay because this one is just on fact
though I'm not that skinny
that's just a fatty
I feel like yeah right on your uterus
right on your uterus that's always my
favorite joke it's a
room
nice job with the air conditioning
all right
I hate this why am I doing this I don't
know scary dude I'm not in this for the
long run I literally
but
flexing in the craziness right
should I flex or no
no not yet don't chill okay feel
it I feel it stop around oh my
God
Crank that okay can I tell you
something it hurts way less gravity for
like too long that's way less really
yeah
wouldn't it be that
make sure to push them down like Pat
them a little bit and it
just hits me like a truck it doesn't
feel any different when I push down
what'd you say Dan
he said
yeah we're in two well when it first
came on I freaked out yeah
I hate it turn it off turn it off oh
just again it feels different it doesn't
I hate it
I'm doing that oh my God
oh my God
it sucks I hate it
you are so dramatic dude
yeah
I ordered it
I have a low tolerance for being
electrocuted
how about that Dan
yeah ladies we're tipping the beanies to
you thank you being less fat than not
having a have an impact okay yeah
I thought it was going to because at
first
it was very gentle it's because he was
on a wine but I remember last time
when it turned on it was already
okay this this seems now this seems just
pathetic of me to post
[Laughter]
this one's like a super mega pathetic we
just need to not do it there's so much
happening here you know I
I Bae I think you just need to quote
tweet it and say wrong
what happens when you L plus ratio and
lose something has to be done that could
be that could literally what's gonna
okay so what happens now wow I mean what
do we do now what do we do that's a
genuine question yeah that could be a
nice response so what do we do to you
now okay let's do that dude there's our
Rachel like there's our Rachel police on
Tick Tock for Twitter
maybe just reply and tag them yeah see
that's what I was wondering okay we are
not the authority on this racer call in
the police
where's the ratio I don't see ratio
please you're gonna snitch
hell yeah I'm gonna snitch
okay so I definitely have seen it in the
past radio officers I typed ratio police
I'm not seeing anything promising
oh here's one or maybe failed ratios or
something
yeah while you're looking for that let
me craft my response maybe do you just
keep sending should we do a new poll of
like over and oversane do we do a new
poll of like don't respond at all quote
with with question mark like the few
options Okay so
okay no response is one option yeah
I don't want him to respond someone says
he's not gonna respond I know it's not
about him it's about the world
it's it's drawing a line in the sand it
says here and no further
it's a red line
he's like the biggest twitch streamer
and he just did a failed ratio like
hello am I the only one that
cares
I wouldn't be surprised if Elon removed
the ratio police account yeah I think so
too
he is that petty of a totally okay
so let's do a poll should I not respond
or just respond with at this point
you've talked a lot about it some people
show that people might send to him
anyway you know what I mean so maybe
he'll get he'll get wind
some people like that they just quote
with like question marks
oh tweet what happens when you when your
L ratio fails okay like that what
happens when your L ratio fails
Dan's rolling his eyes
so what do we do you lost what do we do
now that your ass got owned
where's your fans
it's Friday baby all right listen to
this go ahead there's a subreddit with
43 members called failed Rachel already
members
40 members 40 43. Twitter's the town
hall don't you understand it's the Town
Square the world Town Square I
should have known I don't know the more
the more you suggest ideas I just feel
like nothing is better it's all bad yeah
people just say the worm
no
me when I fail a ratio no
how about the rip Bozo smoking the xqc
pack
it's pretty good we're at bozo like you
know that Meme you know
what happens when you fail a ratio
suck my dude
like that someone and Chad said be the
bigger person
you've clearly not been watching me
what happens when
you fail a ratio I think it needs to be
he needs to be uh
he needs to be banned for a week
reply with kissy lips that's cute or
send you the kissy lips
or like you could say I liked it to help
out
how about it's just a picture of me and
my family like the Homer Simpson one
that is funny
L plus ratio plus family
yeah just the image is funny I mean he
is such a lonely ass loser if that's is
that a low blow
yes I mean yes but it's like lonely that
one is the only one L stands for lonely
oh God
I don't know
L stands for lonely which your ass is I
mean he literally sits in a giant house
in an empty room
housekeeper was in the other day right
and he's afraid to communicate with the
only people that are there cleaning up
his as he's typing to his chat but
they're reading it
the housekeepers were reading yeah
behind him
what about I just quoted it with the
meme the Simpson meme no see that's no
all right I'm out I'm out I'm wasting
too much time Boomer God damn it
it's giving Elon on on Twitter when he
started posting memes
[Music]
sorry
okay here's the poll I'll abide by the
poll should Ethan even reply no Let It
Go pretty close
true I'm gonna abide by this fall
I'm route guys no let it goes at 56 but
I want to Rally
I want everybody to say he needs to
reply to get your best rally in the poll
I need why
okay
45 are moving wait we did a new one what
happened
[Music]
okay wait what's happening okay wait
what's happening
did you guys cheat what no it's the same
one
huh I saw it disappear and come back and
now I'm losing
guys should I respond get Let's Rock the
vote you guys nothing changed unless you
make your voice
everybody someone said it's given Elon
that's what ELO told me bro oh this oh
yeah here it is
oh God this is so up
I'm not showing the kid's face no it's
fine it's a picture I posted but it's an
old one no that's crazy absolutely not
that's crazy
that'd be crazy to post they're saying
who who sent Zach's picture Kim so you
posted this can I show it
isn't this great photo though yeah so
nice
yeah
that
and me and my happy family no that'd be
Psycho no it's psychotic yeah me and my
happy family life outside our house on
your wrist now about just Zach no
mentions of family in your time
[Laughter]
Zach would never me right now after
ratio and you
me trying to play it cool about ratio
and yeah
all right people want me to move on 55
okay guys nothing changes if you don't
vote
don't you go do you don't get to
complain about the elections anymore I
remember if you're still in line
stay in there's 9 000 votes in 43 000
watching I mean
come on that now it's pretty rough it's
a horrible turnout yeah
all you got to do is go click the damn
button
all right we got to move on sorry
everybody
just gonna have to let this one go oh
wait wait
oh oh this is pretty good
what do you think about that
we already no this is what's wrong with
this
we've been around this Bend already I
mean we've talked about it exactly this
tweet them yeah denied just with the
worm I guess the word denied is new
I still we were said listen to them last
pool
no it's the last four the poll is at 55
but this is a good one I like this one
this is my favorite one is this not a
democracy no you're not is that
new to you this is a benevolent
dictatorship you were just talking about
benevolent dictatorship don't make pico
Machiavellian in here because I'll
become a dictator real fast I'll drop
the benevolent Act
laughs we gotta have a revolution
it's done you tried got a 70 1776
this guy you try
uh how's it going
um
[Music]
get the lyrics
all right guys hello we got one more
pull hello
what's the bowl this or nothing
the nine plus worm or nothing
this okay
and remember is it better to be feared
or loved I prefer to be loved Dan but I
can also be feared if that's the road
you want to go
I'm voting for denied and worm
boom
[Music]
I have a tweet that's gonna own you
what happens when you fail to ratio oh
me by the way it's winning it's winning
it was right there the night plus worm
is winning the Great Line guys it's
winning
oh this is big guys is winning
uh what are you guys doing I'll post it
posted already just post all right send
me that uh oh wait send me that image
that exactly no deny though oh what yeah
stay out of it
don't you feel like it's been too long
No I gave him a fair chance to get the
ratio going
you know what I fear though by code
tweeting it is that it will get more
likes
that's a risk that's an inherent risk
okay send it in send it on WhatsApp and
I'm gonna post it
that exact screenshot please Ian thank
you
[Music]
what happens when you're not funny
people stop watching your stream
16 viewers just left me what do you get
when you have ratio
a big fat embarrassing
is that a kid's dancing
[Music]
too much money
you lose a million in Vegas in one night
all right I'm ready
you guys gotta help me out because I
don't I don't I don't want this to go
back
I don't I don't want this to backfire
okay denied
no denied
I want this to end I am so against
having denied in there but I do want
this segment to end
which is L I'm against nothing but the
people said post it no you said post it
no 57 post it that's true denied
um yellow bro took that yo dude just got
ratio done bro dude get a load of this
guy don't change your last minute are
you kidding
okay so I have to write denied then
this is stressful
Chad is gonna agree with me now you need
a new poll because look at that is it
like win tonight or without denial
no denied just him okay all right I'll
do just him I'll do just him that's
that's a bag of tweet guys that's a
banger tweet okay it's out it's up I'm
retweeting about guys please help
please help because if this backfires I
am like I'm the biggest one
please help us guys and now what's gonna
happen xqc is probably gonna start a war
he's like everybody go click biracial
please no it's so embarrassing he would
never be that Grinch I'm so humiliated
he would never do something so pathetic
like that of course no of course not him
all right guys please guys please please
please please oh my gosh here we go oh
zilly zonka's in there
does
[Music]
like an UPA does they on people's
lawn I guess
are okay we're moving on thank you
officially please guys I need your help
now more than ever
please like Henry this is important to
me
listen I have never asked you guys for
every anything
ever look at my squash and you
have a vested interest in because you
inspired me it the ends went through so
yeah send link in chat please yeah that
needs help I'm worried for him
do anything your word for me yeah yeah
guys listen
10 years I've been doing this I have
never asked you guys for anything
how much have I done for you I'm here
every day
and you're just sitting on the couch I
ask you this this one time I calling out
for your help please like this tweet for
me
because if I get ratioed I don't know if
I'm able to come back here
so if you like this show you'll like
that tweet because if I get ratio the
podcast is done it's over
I'm ending the show I can't come back
it's humiliating I I put that stake now
this shit's gonna be locked and loaded
anytime now
that's what's at stake everything what's
at stake everything
almost it's almost there
oh we almost already ratio yeah 29 17.
what's at stake Everything Jesus
all right thank you all right we'll
continue to check up on it okay we did
the we did the uh the P the period
simulator well done love
horribly done to me fairly to be fair
um Logan Paul's so boring but he got in
a prime controversy he's being indicted
indicted no I'm kidding he's not oh but
he went on Fox news with sharks he went
on with charts which reminds me
of these boneheads in Congress who bring
up these charts like they're both morons
so here he is I think well we'll talk
about it but you're about a hundred away
I'm leaning Logan on this one so sorry
to interrupt we have a successful ratio
oh my God guys don't get complacent do
not get complacent okay wow this is
still an open election you have to keep
the votes the likes coming right
otherwise he still has a shot you know
they call them dumps he might be coming
out with big thumbs
up big bands of dumps
all right so what's the controversy
let's see uh blah blah blah blah
there's too much caffeine in their
a news conference Chuck Schumer came for
them yeah dude this is a big deal what
I'm Chuck Schumer
is talking about prime he is rallying
the troops he wants the FDA so he's
being investigate him that's not what an
indictment is well he could be indicted
I'm saying if Chuck Schumer's evolved no
I mean it's my boy Chucky
laughs
it's a big deal he says uh
the Prime energy drink
has caffeine levels equivalent to 12
ounces of Coca-Cola
that's disgusting is it 12 what I don't
think that you read that right at all
six 12 ounces cans of Coca-Cola yeah
yeah that's that is unacceptable that is
just unacceptable
12 ounce Prime energy contains 200
milligrams of caffeine I've seen drinks
with that all the time like in the
fridge next door this is 200 milligrams
of caffeine that's pretty normal right
well that is what Logan's saying so
maybe you are Logan after all I'm not
I'll I'll lie to myself if I need to
I'll forget that I know that
yeah no 200 200 milligrams
what the how do you survive that
compared with the 114 milligrams of
caffeine at 12 ounce can of Red Bull
200. or the 100 grams found in a cup of
coffee are you real good bitching that
it's two cup of coffee what are you
doing this Chuck don't you have better
things to worry about you dumb
loser
Chuck Schumer go do your job
sounds pretty similar to what Logan was
saying and now actually the worst part
is they got Logan Paul out here looking
presentable with glasses and now
people can be like oh I guess she's a
serious I was wondering about that
does he these glasses have you ever seen
him wearing glasses I mean not uh
colorblind glasses I don't know I don't
think so he put them on for this our
audience they gave him such a dug on the
left so stupid for me do we post all
right I just want to cut to the chase
now Logan thank you very much this is so
this is pure propaganda this is prime
propaganda do you think Schumer was in
on it I don't know but this seems like a
PR plan
it's a PR plant
look at that they're just advertising
their products look at this this is just
straight up okay yeah no in this part if
you actually watch this they're
criticizing it saying look it's hard to
distinguish the one on the left is like
a Gatorade like product and the one on
the right is the energy drink too they
look right The Branding makes it hard to
tell them apart that's that's what fox
is saying good Hawaii is on fire
the whole island
let's you know what I mean
Paul is with us he owns Prime and he's
with us right now also he just ran like
a prolific scam right well that's you
know what I mean let's not talk about
let's not talk about prime let's talk
about the scam he just pulled thank you
very much for being on this or how much
you are is that Lou Dobbs he looks
the same old ass crusty white guy ripped
to the goat dude I was Lou passed I
don't I don't know but he looks like
he's just ripped but he's got to be
going soon I love the name Lou Dobbs I'm
sure Louis boy will appreciate that
Dobbs
how do you respond kids can't easily
distinguish the difference
this is an app um I mean this is a
softball right off the rip I'd say
that's preposterous one is in a can and
says energy drink on it the others in a
bottle it says hydration drink on it uh
one is 18 plus the other is suitable for
all ages and we believe it do they ID
you to buy energy drinks they do not and
Logan suggests maybe they should maybe
that would be a better solution to this
than coming after individual companies
uh well also he should put out a drink
well listen he knows
we all know it's kids buying this
or well no no people like it but a lot
of kids are buying this
you know what I mean
well that is why they are being singled
out is because their marketing is
targeted towards kids that's what
smoking you scumbag well done as good as
Chris come you should look you should
look at their marketing and see if you
think that that's the case okay put on
okay let's look at the marketing can you
play ding dunk
job as we possibly can differentiating
our products but do you think that the
high energy drink it's full of caffeine
yeah yeah
[Music]
I don't care about anything but making
money I'm jealous of my little brother
okay you know what I could give you he
is insanely good at wrestling
is number one hater but that guy is
incredible at wrestling I don't even
know how he does that so what do we do
them at the point of purchase to make
this is so dumb okay moronic
checking in on the ratio
[Laughter]
6 000 pretty good how long how long ago
was this posted
nine minutes that's it no
I think so nine minutes what do you mean
no I felt like longer
oh okay
guys please get your
baby
I wish I noticed earlier
Amazon here Justice for denied thank you
to everybody who's participating
everybody's getting likes from me
here's loves I'm looking for all you
guys so I can support love worm L
he don't got it it should not be you
know what you need to get get that off
the scratch dangerous scrolling Twitter
is no
okay that's a gift then now exists yeah
there you go H3 gift
it gives us so far so here send me your
tweets so I can like them cam sent me
his directly
oh you posted it that's good that's good
yeah it's doing good too ratio did not
being suppressed by uh big Tech though
this is awesome this is good okay now
this is fun it's turning into a dumb
question that's why you gotta get that
chunky cam is that yeah I gotta paint it
we're gonna get you that check here for
sure no I don't want it it's just it's
just eight dollars a month should I
retweet this or no oh wait no my account
no yeah it's not even my account no no
no
all right and then is there one you
wanted me to look at love
nope okay you already looked at it guys
get your likes in I've never asked for
anything in my life
you owe it to me
[Music]
you owe me likes on Twitter
or I'll stop doing this show forever
if I lose the ratio
I will never come back and do a show I
guess it would be a good time to fire
off a tweet you know you got one tell me
when it's up well no I commented that
but also on top of that I feel like it's
a good time to fire off a tweet oh just
unrelated I wrote little little wormy
boy oh you sent me a link okay yeah
Olivia's always cooking some tweets up
yeah I like your Twitter thinking about
it I like your Twitter yeah but you
didn't you just sent me I don't know I
commented it oh you got to send me the
link because I don't want to see porn on
here that's too risky I did I
[Music]
did
but I do that
I wasn't trying to do anything like
racially there let me be clear just
terrific I was speaking in tongues
nobody thought that okay good now they
did
little wormy boy
thank you all right moving on thank you
such a Banner song
it's so sick it's straight like from a
Christmas special
it's amazing though what is it what does
it say to you this song what do you
imagine
it says a lot
[Music]
it's giving me
Home Alone
at the house yes exactly something is
about to happen exactly
anyone else trolls and fairies
yeah
Swedish trolls
I think Luigi's Mansion Louise's Mansion
is right off
I'm feeling Scoopy and Shaggy walking
down a haunted Hall looking for Clues
definitely this is tiptoe music
[Music]
[Laughter]
here we go
Haunted Mansion line at Disney yeah wait
Zach unbuttoned this shirt yeah
why not dude what are you talking about
are you going Philip DeFranco on me or
what all right let's talk about uh you
guys want to talk about the fortnite
Holocaust Museum sure do you want to
talk about Bento luck being exposed that
I'm in your walls Ben guy or Lil Tay
being alive
uh the bentelect thing is
pretty funny actually or I found some
more stuff on the mental like thing too
that guy is so pathetic let's do
that one and we've talked about him he's
this guy on on uh Tick Tock he just
steals people's videos and goes whoa
that's crazy
and so people started with him
yeah yeah
which has turned into a really fantastic
meme yeah
so
here's an example of one of his is he
still banging on oh yes he is 11 million
Boston
and it's still just like the same thing
like the one the third one
with the text behind him
uh yeah let's click this one therapist
you're overthinking what if don't what
if don't what if everyone else is under
thinking do you think he's cute until
it's time to send a picture
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah a lot of people
and he is the xqc of tick tock if you
think about it
hmm
thank you for that analogy
and so um here's another one yes but yes
I'm finally verified but everybody else
is no
got them
256 gigs should be plenty but just
kidding you're out of space
coffee design but you put the lid on
it's basically who can relate ah no
shorts in the club my bad but the girls
can wear something relax
secret Beach no one will be there JK
it's packed with peace
of toys for my dog surely he will chew
those but instead
gym equipment can't wait to use it yeah
this is like my brain I feel my brain is
suffering an aneurysm opening up yeah
you know so okay now let's talk about
what's going on now that I've joined so
Jordan Max is a so his name is not Ben
no this is talking about someone else oh
okay I'm talking about a girl who this
story involves named Jordan Max
she's a famous online personality she
has a of account um okay
and she exposed uh screenshots of her
dealing with this famous quote famous
Tick Tock dirt tick tocker who is Ben
collect hmm
was she cryptic about it or At first she
did not she did not say his name she
just called him a famous tick tocker and
then in the follow-up tweets you'll see
when she knows
I don't know who she is by the way let
me I'm just Googling
I just want to see your face okay well
her Instagram is in
right here but there's a note to not put
it on screen okay let me open this real
fast it's fairly risque oh interesting
okay
oh interesting oh interesting that's it
sounded bad
okay so she put out uh DNS
okay
so when Jordan
declined wait what just skip to see
yeah okay here's the screenshots okay
so I was invited can I open this or is
this just a general one about her I can
open this right yeah
so she says I was invited to be on a
podcast by a pretty popular Tick Tock
Creator and three hours before we were
supposed to record he asked me if I
wanted to make an only fans video which
I declined one hour before we were
supposed to meet up he canceled and this
is why check this out
this is text message with this
freak do you want to make a video for
only fans when
today today no she says you need a STD
test
within the last 14 days and you need an
of account I mean a video for your page
doing what
I don't know what performs the best for
your page
I don't uh I was just thinking you're
helping me doing a video for YouTube so
maybe I could help you with your only
fans oh my God
this seems like a fair Exchange
obviously an eye for an eye you know
what I need to see is him reading these
like his tick tock
it's a fun idea true girl
she says I'm good thanks thanks though
no worries
hey we're gonna do the pickle video with
someone else thanks though what the
what also that was what they were
supposed to do too oh that was okay okay
she says okay any particular reason why
uh uh to be honest I thought it would be
just to be fun to film and see where
things go but I got it
she also clarifies that the pickle idea
was her idea so he just took the idea
what so she's okay best of luck tasting
pickle tasting video coming soon
does anyone watch his content outside
like I can't imagine people are actually
well so I I as I was reading through the
story
I was struck by this line that don't
scroll don't stop scrolling wait
seriously this is what you're on and
then send me a folder it's uh
there's a backup right below okay
all right
but yeah anyways so she's saying she was
gonna invited to do his podcast I was
like oh the bent elect podcast I wonder
what that's all about right oh yeah so
so the podcast uh it's brand new and you
know it's hard to find your
feet when you're starting a podcast you
know it's this man will convert zero
people well here let's do I mean to his
podcast let's let's see
[Laughter]
hold on this guy has so little clout so
little clout and he's already trying to
extort women and to have sleeping with
him 5 000 view yeah on episode three
um his channel does have over three
million subscribers though oh it's
probably YouTube shorts
[Music]
and that's proof right you have three
million fans and 5 000 people watched
your popular menu uh yeah I mean it's
not terrible on the shorts oh wow yeah
some are like insane yeah you mean all
right you called it yeah Ben all right
well do you want to check out the
podcast okay how are you I'm good how
are you
how are you how are you good morning
welcome back to another episode of elite
podcast I am Ben and I'm Ashley Ashley
what is your last name Ashley Ashley
Astor best name ever oh can we reach out
to her it's all right sounds like a
professional player my chemistry teacher
was always like you know you're like an
astrologer what does she do she's like
you're you're going to be like an
astronaut can you Google I want I'm just
wondering if she's an OS person
you're like you know actually hockey
player I'm like I'm just a hockey hockey
star or whatever
their names
[Music]
[Laughter]
what I'm wondering is is he just
inviting oaf girls because because this
whole thing is just a ploy right for him
to try that not only of girls but that's
his second episode
was is she an oaf girl that's just what
I'm wondering maybe you you Google I'm
looking yeah
if you put her info in the bio he didn't
even plug her no literally
what well it's only 5 000 views I found
her Instagram
uh retired athlete okay
any of links
oh it says keep it spicy that's a
thousand percent of
huh so he's inviting only fans girls
dude you're a creep bro yep what giving
major major creep and who is his first
guest hold on can you pull up that
channel again
uh yeah I think it's this video actually
you know what check your walls Ben
girls who are visiting Ben because
there's probably a camera in it
I'm inside your walls that's the camera
talking that he hid there
Benjamin it is
what is it
today we're going to talk about
grievances you didn't say what his real
name is Benjamin Benjamin I think she
said it what then your name is Ben
so your name is Ben said people think
his name's Ben to let oh oh nobody
thinks that nobody thinks that yeah so
is she an of model uh she just said her
first name so I don't know is there any
information about who that is he doesn't
introduce her I'm
okay yeah ab's on it so here let me
continue these DMS as we uh investigate
so she says
we were gonna do a pickle taste testing
mukbang video podcast which was my idea
in the first place but now he's just
gonna take my idea and do it with
someone else typical I thought
because you're a sex worker you're
constantly looking to do the labor for
free that in the midst of eating pickles
like we talked about you'd randomly want
to have sex but now that I can't
manipulate you I don't want to do the
video because I'm a shitty person that's
yeah yeah
basically yes
um that is crazy it is
uh and then she tagged them so yeah uh
wearing your walls band did he go
private yeah he's yeah good idea
you suck I can't believe this
conversation he had with her well you
know you assume he's a douche based on
the content he makes yeah
but now
we really know
yeah it looks like
he he contacted her too a few
if you scroll down
so to be uh transparent and fair the
first girl is not an of person
okay second and third ones are
let's see Jordan was then I don't really
know that about this thing
then reached out by Creator who okay so
now she's he's threatening to sue her
now
here's Ben tlect what
um for what
now I can open these right guys because
maybe I'll just open the backup
okay just pull up the backup so now
she tagged him
okay and then he DMS her you need to
take this tweet down or I will sue you
he talks like a child
he talks like he's never talked to other
humans yes dude he it's like he's a
clone or something
do you want to make an only fans video
yeah
he used uh chat uh
way
he needed to write this sentence for him
yeah
okay
so and then uh Jordan then posted
screenshots of another woman who
experienced the same thing with Benny
boy
check this out
turns out I'm not the only one Bentley
has tried this with another woman who
wishes to stay Anonymous DM me with
screenshots of their conversation Ben so
do you work tomorrow sorry crazy busy
day I don't work tomorrow no no worries
let's make some content tomorrow not
like that but just film a podcast what
do you think you're killing me gorgeous
slick brother you're killing me gorgeous
[Laughter]
I've also been thinking about this of
thing and I think I can make us a lot of
money straight up
hey sorry I've been M.I.A today but I've
had him I'm taking a mental health day
no response I love that
so he wants to be like an of performer
like I'm confused by what his angle is
just go start jerking off and put it on
of bro yeah just go do your own thing
you have a twin brother that you can
make out with
that that works apparently for tick
Tuckers
he keeps going hey you do you want to
come over tomorrow night ooh night
actually are you down to come over
tonight
or are you just gonna flake oh no he's
going nice guy on her Ben
yeah sorry babe but you're just too much
of a flick bye
you know and then she responds you know
if you wouldn't have texted me so rudely
calling me a flake after one day of not
texting you might have stood a chance I
can see why you're single now goodbye yo
she was she there was a shot for him out
in some world
yeah whatever go yourself
says the girl who's trying to make an
only fans what are you doing
you're the one you're trying to ride
their only fans uh coattails
pubic uh
there's a better analogy because they're
naked
hairs probably not that long I don't
want to insult them
[Applause]
um
and then she responds first you want to
make content with me and now you're
throwing it in my face laugh my ass off
save your words you're just a flake if
you were actually up front I'd be down
but you probably have a lot going on
which is understandable but either way I
honestly don't care yeah cool then stop
texting me it seems like it
she he keeps no shot he's trying
to pay her now wait what is why does it
look different now this is on another
platform oh and snap you moved it over
to Snapchat where everything goes down
we're all sexual predatory behavior and
our messages are erased
yeah so he says do you want to come over
here and spend some time with me because
on a side note I do think I could
probably make us some money on only fans
because Ben he referred to himself in
the first person he said Ben to like
crazy it's a title suggestion
uh into Oblivion no he's just like the
name of the person is censored oh okay
this guy thinks he's into Oblivion
he'd be like
again no I don't want this guy's so
gross
if you come over I'll give you a
thousand dollars
I just really want you
I'm good right now don't try to bribe me
with money that's weird
no that is weird but I want to see you
oh my God and this guy whoa he is
disgusting that's what I'm saying the
littlest amount of clout like I don't
think he has one actual fan
but also the kind of guy to like reach
out to them because they do only fans to
then say like oh you're an only fans
like
as a as an insult probably there is
definitely I've noticed some kind of
thing like with sex workers where people
just assume that because they do sex
work they're just like anyone can
them for any reason
yeah it's really gross it's like hey you
do sex work let's come over here and
me
you do tick tocks come make some tick
tocks for me for free right hey come
read me memes in my living room yeah I
want a live performance come launch my
social page a little bit for a day
another one is this another one
another woman yo there's a third one
somebody wrote in there that's good
he is a benzo yep
another woman has come to me she said
wishing to remain on Anonymous sharing
her experience this dude is a predator
he really is
um I thought we were besties that's the
name someone just gifted 100 memberships
thank you so much or Prince wow I'm
guessing
oh it's Prince
thank you uh possibly thank you to our
Saudi benefactor
it's not under the usual name so it
could be somebody else but whoever it is
thank you we are besties you thought
right you you were right
so she said so here's the message
oh man
hi I'm so sorry you went through that
with that guy no shot he's gonna segue
that
huh he's he's responding to a post of
her talking about trauma she had with
the guy he's trying to Segway no this is
yeah I don't think so this is somebody
messaging her to tell their story yeah
all right just read the message
I hooked up with him a while in 19 and
20 back when he was attempting to be a
rapper
hold on oh we need one second he's a
pretty shady guy we matched on Tinder
and he said he was 25 but later he told
me he was 29.
holy why would you lie
uh I when I was trying to stop hooking
up he kept telling me that he seriously
excuse me
wanted to try dating after seeing him
another time he told me he wasn't
looking for anything serious oh my God
then gaslit me that he never said
anything like that with me
he called me crazy and said he hopes I
find help I found out you already had a
girlfriend and when I told her she told
me that he was 31.
she told me he also lied to her when
they started dating this is Jimmy Lee
energy
the other way no he's lying about how
young he is oh Jimmy Lee does that he
says
he grew up in the 90s like us
she told me he also lied to her when
they started dating she was younger than
me and he had said that he was in his
early 20s what to her he was literally
lying to hook up with the younger girl
on Tinder at the time I think I was like
23. holy
wow
oh yeah if it's gonna get claimed
it's not worth it you want to put on
headphones and just give it uh so
somebody's checking right now
um but I suspect because it's just your
kid did this like I claimed but um no
friends it's called no friends
oh that's actually it's called no
friends oh friends yeah
yeah yeah
wow is it just him crying like I got no
friends the chorus is I never had no
friends I never had no friends who
Spears with friends very robot well I
think what he knows this this one is a
short um it didn't get claimed really
this is different
oh you gave me a different one this one
did not get claimed yeah okay
going too far
thinking that fast
[Laughter]
um I love his Smosh from 2000 haircut
the Smosh guys changed their do man
didn't you get the memo so there it is
he was bentalik but now he's
inside Ben still Ben cell I like that so
clever Ben not erect
fun not a wreck
do you guys remember that Tick Tock he
had where he said top five people hated
me number one Ela Klein oh
I totally forgot about that yeah
and now you just deemed him
Ben cell move us up to number one dude
because you I'm calling you a predator
yep I'm your new number one hater
oh here it is
I don't think we were baffled at the
time oh you are number one
this is before I knew you were a creep
yeah
yeah yeah
top five people who hate me number one
Gila Klein she looks like I haven't
smiled in years so oh he does insult you
okay I have a creep radar I probably
already could sense it
interesting that's true I do that's a
good point not surprised
you haven't smiled in ages Ela otherwise
you would like him only people that
smile like me
uh
there it is guys Ben select
uh or no
[Applause]
uh
here is a girl that's waiting for me a
rainy day out here I want to date you
psych I am lying I just wanna you
what do you get when you're dating a
creep where's my Shoop I before we go
let's talk about the Holocaust thing
because actually it's so funny fortnite
is close to adding a holocaust museum to
fortnite we literally made this joke
I wonder when the um
yeah you know it's interesting it's an
interesting opportunity
so we made this joke and now it's
happening fortnite's first Holocaust
museum has been approved by epic games
what
okay
[Music]
this is from the MLK interactive event
right okay wow now this is actually
right this is a alphabet get ready for
his life so
wow oh that is still
pretty good
oh you made an AI Ben
I've got a perfect puzzle for you
if you are wise you'll listen to me uh
what do you get when you guzzle down
sweets eating as much as an elephant
eats what are you at getting terribly
fat what do you think
you did that this fast yeah was there
already
it's it's super easy to train like on AI
because all his videos are so monotone
and no audience all this tick tocks you
just put in the username and then it
scans no no I had to select things how
many did you feed it uh 16. oh that's
crazy
fortnite will soon get a new interactive
experience that aims to educate players
about the Holocaust I mean Valiant uh
valuable you know
uh intentions game developer Luke
Bernard shared that epic games has
approved a virtual Holocaust themed
Museum to be added to the game hmm
here it is
here's some uh stills
I just don't know why do you need it in
a video game
you know what I I get where it's coming
from because
these gamers are like
the mo there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of there are a lot of
Nazis
um yeah yeah that's even more of a
reason not to do it because is this not
just in like inviting like this is
obviously going to get trolled and to
face well I don't know I think there'll
be some people who come here and learn
something
yeah look at her look how serious
how reverent she is I thought this was
like an onion article yeah we sent it
this morning break it down
Crystal not baby
go down for Christmas
[Music]
oh God it's so dark John or John Wick is
that his name yeah John Wick's about to
be in the Holocaust Museum it's powerful
Darth Vader Thanos right Thanos I don't
think Inspector Gadget
so the uh the ADL did a like
investigation and like gave like ratings
different games
um in terms of like anti-Semitism online
and they gave fortnite an F Well there
it is and so I think yeah this Creator
defended them and and uh they did this
class yeah before we come to a decision
let's look into it this is the virtual
space
I guarantee that people are gonna be
making swastika because they're bright
outside
although you could put out a band for
that just have someone from
Riot just sitting out there
40 days Epic
epic yeah whatever who cares cares
nice building good lighting frankly I
will say it looks a little more
Tastefully done than the MLK one like
because the MLK one had like jumping
puzzles and yeah right right
Fortnight yeah this one looks pretty I
mean it's pretty cool if you divorce it
from fortnite yeah now imagine just a
banana running through here
so
yeah I mean at least they're not like
Holocaust deniers I guess well right
yeah it was meant to comment that
actually that's one of the main reasons
they were talking about it when the
Creator so here's some more info as for
those concerns if this new initiative
would be do more bad than good Luke
informed another post that emojis
destruction and weapons are disabled in
the map
um
he writes it's more protected than even
memorials where people take selfies
emotes disabled these are emojis emotes
emotes disabled
so when he's when they say map
that's like you teleport into this Zone
yeah okay so they're not going to drop
in you just you actually you parachute
and you just smash through the uh
through the Skylight okay you flying
through the Smoke Stack and it's it's
really sick to wait till the last second
so you're just like bam through the
window and you pop the parachute yeah
where are we Landing boys right
they just they need they need to be
aware that people are going to stand and
make swastikas outside they're gonna do
all that so just be ready for that
yeah and in fact so much so that uh the
opening of the virtual museum has been
delayed after Nick Fuentes rallied all
of his anti-semitic friends to attack it
that's right I'm sure the the new
culture wars being fought in Fortnight
my friends kids loved
Hill it's the front line yeah this is
the front line yeah Call of Duty has
like uh zombie Nazis and fortnite has
real Nazis yeah that's awesome Call of
Duty has real Nazi
oh virtual
oh I'm saying the players yeah after
news of the games uh launch caught
attention of Fuentes he sent a message
to his telegram chat subscribers with
screenshots from an interview Bernard
gave in January speaking about his
depression and the negative influence
funtis had on fortnite players yeah they
previously had a back and forth related
to just online anti-Semitism in general
he is such a vile freak yeah like you
know
he really is just a vile nasty
weirdo
um
Luke is concerned that Fuentes Cult of
anti-Semitic followers will somehow
disrupt the Museum's opening which was
scheduled for this week I'm waiting
until things died down Bernard said it
will never they're waiting Bernard I
guarantee Luke I just oh thank you Luke
I just don't want the Nazis to go in and
do Nazi things when it launches first of
all uh Luke if you're watching
I have some advice for you first of all
stop dissing the Nazis all the time you
gotta disable the Skins shut up Kanye
no skins because you're gonna have
bananas you're gonna have Thanos you're
gonna have John Wick in there it's gonna
be silly nonsense I mean even the
even the normal characters are silly
nonsense it's like a cartoon it just
doesn't not feel fortnite is not the
appropriate venue for Holocaust
Education full stop I'll tell you how
we'll stop I'll tell you how to do it I
I agree with you Dan I think it should
just be like a POV type thing
I don't think there should be characters
in there I think it's just no third
perspective exactly I think it's just
but then how do the other people look
because you see them but what do you
mean perhaps there's other people there
right I'm saying when you enter the
section of the Holocaust Museum you
don't see other people I think this is a
perfect time to actually dropped the
Ethan Klein skin they've been teasing
you must use the H3 skin yeah perfect
that'll win me a whole bunch of friends
on the internet
yeah don't so you got to disable the
skins and also you gotta have someone
like monitoring that map I don't know if
that's possible but there will for sure
they're just gonna be painting swastikas
on the grass outside a thousand percent
that will happen no matter how long you
wait yep yeah yeah they'll find a way I
mean these Cycles go hard they might
even do like pixel art of like Adolf
Hitler's face like they would they could
do and would do that they'll find a way
yeah
but to be fair if he I I don't hate the
idea because I do think that
this is important education for young
people who may not be exposed to this
and maybe some people will go in there
and learn something I don't know I
suppose yeah
Spectators view that's what it's called
it seems like epic games learned from
the MLK event not to allow emotes near
these things they're made slowly they've
learned yeah but if they allow skins in
there this is going to be a total
show
I think people are going to want their
skins because they're then people won't
go but then you you can't you gotta give
the kids some you can't do it if they're
skins you can't do it it's just too
silly so what would they walk in as just
the default just default yeah
I guess that's fair again like I said I
think it should just be like a POV thing
you don't see any other characters it's
just your for your eyes only
I think the vast majority of people
going there will be with the express
purpose of trolling it
the best fast majority
I feel like this is just nothing but a
Target yeah it's probably gonna listen
like I said are there is there a uh Star
Wars stormtrooper um yes skin there it
is the SS storm dorm Trooper yeah
boom there it is that's true 200 people
marching around the Holocaust Museum the
Stormtroopers all right
not good not good
um
I like the idea but I expect this to be
a total disaster yeah
so but I uh eagerly await
Jean-Luc
or just Luke actually Luke Bernard
and that's that
thank you Luke thank you thank you
well that's that my friends oh wait let
me check on the tweet
yeah how are you doing how are we doing
all right it's a it's a it's a decent
showing again there's 41 000 people
um yes Cam to your question
thank you
we're at 11
0003.
now here my concern is okay he's not
getting that much more likes
that's good
bro it's a dub right there okay you're
good okay walk away walk away walk away
wash your hands yep
so guys remember don't look back just
remember as you log off as you go to
enjoy this weekend you owe me
like this tweet
or I'm never coming back
music
[Music]
xqc it has a tiny p p
his girlfriend I'm not gonna go there
not gonna go there
all right
that's it that's it that's the show
thanks for watching everybody
thanks for watching Everybody
great great week have a great weekend
all the audience you're very welcome
and uh
uh thank you to Howie Mandel just
because yeah right what's this look at
this fortnite has approved a holocaust
museum this is so sick I can't wait to
throw it down in there dude
oh it's as good as an ally okay or throw
it down throw it on you said throw it on
when I made it all right guys thank you
everyone for watching have a great
weekend we'll see you on Monday bye bye
thank you